bye
today i'm pleased
today i'm today i'm
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
[Music]
convalescent
from the blood of recovered patients to
help treat patients battling a current
infection convalescence
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
we provided 48 million to fund the mayo
clinic study that tested the
efficacy of convalescence
the virus
[Music]
convalescence
all right welcome everybody as promised
8 30 p.m
in the east 5 30 p.m in the west very
very late at night for our european
friends
and family i guess and we are here for
the first
presidential debate uh joseph r biden jr
and donald j trump to be moderated by
chris
wallace of fox news fame and
i predict it is going to be a wild wild
night
allegations of juicing are running
rampant
allegations of earpieces are running
rampant and by that i mean just trump
talking about it joe biden's just been
preparing for a debate
uh but we we have a i believe a very
very special evening ahead of us i
considered actually wearing a shirt and
tie for this one
then i realized my mom's gonna get
really weirded out if i go into her
basement to stream
wearing a shirt and tie so i decided not
to do that
not to do that no shirt and tie today i
did eat a pair though
bartlett none of that boss nonsense give
me a break boss
people um but it's gonna be a very
very powerful night so what what to
expect um a few different things to
to discuss here and i see the the super
chats i see them i see all of it i'm
gonna do my best
to get to everything today um i see
people
signing up for memberships and all of
these different things i will do
everything i can to manage the stream
with the level of professionalism you've
come to us
expect which is like a four out of ten
probably and that's i think what we're
going for tonight
um i actually would go further you know
donald trump has been talking about
joe biden should submit to a drug test
joe biden should submit to a physical
inspection to see
if he's wearing a wire so to speak an
earpiece of some kind i i actually
tweeted
a few minutes ago and uh that we
we actually should not only have drug
tests i want a weigh-in
so we can determine once and for all
whether trump's really weighs
239 you know where my money is on that
one
we should have an iq test so we can see
if trump really is a genius we can have
a neuro psych eval to see if trump is
really stable
and maybe throw arm wrestling in there
why not maybe also a comparison
of uh uh well sats we couldn't do
because
trump got that shapiro kid to take the
not ben shapiro some other guy last name
shapiro
i would love a height check to see if
trump really is as tall as tom brady my
guess is that he's not
i want if we're really going to do this
let's not just do a drug test let's do
the entire thing
you all know what i'm talking about um
of course none of these things are
happening and actually it's
it's a um it's a it's a planned
strategy the right of the trump is right
decided today talk about drugs
that biden could be on and talk about a
wire because trump can't win on
substance trump's losing this on
substance now that all being said
i do want to remind you guys the
there are some tighter polls lately we
got a general election poll today from
harvard harris which is not a bad
pollster
that says it's biden plus two hillary
won by more than two
in the popular vote and donald trump is
president so when you see biden plus two
i don't like it when you see biden plus
two in wisconsin
i don't like that when you see a tie in
arizona
arizona was supposedly going blue blue
blue i don't like it
i don't like it my friends uh trump also
now plus one in north carolina so the
polling from today
is not good it's not good uh
and so we all need to be very very much
aware
uh this is pbs's pre-debate coverage we
need to be very very much aware
that this is not this is not to say it's
not that it's not over it's not even
started yet it's not even started yet so
i would encourage you to go
you can find a page on vote.org it's
vote.org
slash absentee hyphen ballot
no matter where you live i mean if you
live in france it's just gonna tell you
you can't vote obviously but
if you uh live in the united states or
have a legal address here and are voting
absentee
it will tell you in your state how to
request an absentee ballot that's
vote.org
slash absentee hyphen that's the dash
not the underscore the dash
absentee hyphen ballot okay
very very important you can also look at
vote.org
early voting and you can figure out in
your state if early voting is going on
this is only getting started my friends
this is just the very
very beginning um okay let me look at a
couple of super chats
and a couple of twitch messages and a
couple of new members
i have fresh memes i have a lot for you
uh and incredibly we've got uh
we've got almost 25 000 people watching
on reddit already
nothing has started yet there's no
debate yet we've got 25 000 of you here
and and we love it
uh and very very exciting we actually
got to 1.02 million youtube subscribers
today
okay so a lot going on today um
let's see here mark fillion asks if
anybody has odds
i've seen that the betting line is on
biden winning the debate
but each side is going to claim victory
and we'll see if we get a look at some
of the spin room
after the fact other super chats here
that are interesting nathan shocker says
this will be the strongest most powerful
stream
in david deepak pakman show history
believe me folks
you've never seen numbers like this
before someone told me we could get 100k
live concurrent today i don't see it i
don't see that happening
christian black asks whether i saw
trump's brain malfunction at his
jacksonville rally he stops midway
through the word unconstitutional
it's on pbs's youtube channel around 10
minutes in no
let me see if i can find that um
i think i might have a way to find it
more quickly
trump has those glitches often um trump
unconstitutional and we'll look at
videos
uh where is that
okay yeah it's and uh our friend aaron
rupar said that it sounded like
gregorian
gregorian chanting uh i i'm looking
forward to hearing this let's take a
look
oh here we go oops no that's just a
picture
where is that uh hold on a second
here it is far left justices would
release
violent criminals shield foreign
terrorists
impose sanctuary cities and declare
the death penalty totally
unconstitutional
hey it will be totally unconstitutional
they want to declare it unconstitutional
okay
that is that is not so good that is not
so good
and declare the death penalty totally
unconstitutional
hey it will be told that's that brain
glitch yep that's that's what that is
and
from the from the standpoint of medical
i don't know what that is
uh but it was very very gregorian
certainly i i
no no doubt about that okay we now have
video
in the room i always try to bring
everybody video in the room
this looks like um
this looks like people who may be voting
for the wrong guy
that's what it looks like to me is that
marcia blackburn maybe
um how are masks not required in the
room
how is that even get how is that even
allowed unbelievable
okay some very powerful super chats i do
want to say thanks to arthur van
merwick who with a 50 euro super chat
says are you in your mom's basement
this amount should go to you getting
your own place i really want to get my
own place soon guys yes please please
send money
uh lavic says hey you liberal but
extremely
intellectually honest hack if by hack i
mean person this is another 50
super chat you always have such fair
viewpoints even i as a former republican
no idea what i am now but i ain't
progressive agree with almost everything
you say
labik you sound like a progressive to me
my friend you sound like a like a
progressive to me
um okay this is mark meadows i think
donald trump's completely unhinged
chief of staff over on twitch very
exciting things are happening
and neptune has grabbed a sub comrade
has grabbed the sub sub stoned knoll
jesus in the pit we are at the very very
tail end of september
september and i don't want to miss that
um oh there are new members as well hold
on let me get caught up on those as well
joinedpakman.com signups mark
imbilisieri is new member number one
michael striplin is number two april
medrano
is number three duncan warren has signed
up at joinedpakman.com
nick larson is number five kelly shepard
is number six lou okay no you're not
going to get me
louis syenas i'm gonna be very careful
with that one is number eight
you almost got me connie mccarley is
number nine
tim gwain is number ten i love it we
have set
the the goal of 50 today um just because
oh i had the wrong zoom level there
but we are uh we are going to look at a
lot of different things here
okay i have some fresh memes for people
okay let me let me see what i have
actually um
oh oh oh this before we get to memes
this is the news side of fox news if you
can imagine this is the news side of fox
news floating the conspiracy
that biden may have a hidden earpiece to
be fed answers tonight
peter ducey is reporting some
interesting things if it's based on
peter ducey's report we can essentially
dismiss it but let's listen anyway
thanks john i don't know if you've got
these nuggets yet or not but i'll read
them for our viewers
you know the trump team asked to inspect
the ears of each debater for electronic
devices or
or transmitters the buying team has not
consented to that
the bind team wanted to break every 30
minutes the trump team said we will not
have
that uh what more can you fill in about
those requests
those are significant you know first of
all the breaks
are set by the debate commission so the
trump campaign may not have agreed to it
but also the debate commission has
always said that it's 90 minutes
straight through
yeah that's one of the things where
trump's demanding all this stuff like he
has a say
trump has no say over any of this stuff
and that's how they plan for it and
that's what they told the networks
that's what we're planning for
as far as our coverage as far as the
listening devices
and the biden campaign's response to
that
i think that's interesting and we're
gonna have to follow that through the
day
uh to you know what comes out of that
yeah it's super interesting to look for
for devices okay here is um
this is this is whoa hold on a second i
actually need to mute this for
copyright purposes this is deep fake
pacman here to get you guys through the
oh david thor
pacman we will be defending the audience
okay take a look at this
this is really really well done that's
me with a beard
there i am love it
i would prefer like a more modern outfit
i feel like
okay anyway so we've got that uh what
else did i have for you guys oh a very
very nice article on the wrap yesterday
which i don't actually have a
subscription to
about how well the streams have been
going and the youtube clips have been
going
if i try to scroll i get a paywall but i
found the article
and it has some very very interesting
things here
for example where does it mention ah
here for example the david pakman show a
progressive news show based out of
boston pulled in 767
000 views on its most popular video
between saturday and monday
it topped hello it topped the view count
on all but one video posted by msnbc
during that same time period
the most watched cnn clip between
saturday and monday had about 500
000 views pacman during an interview
with the rap which was like a year ago
six months ago
said his channel has grown to one
million subscribers based on two factors
quality production
that what they mean by that is the blue
panels behind me and most importantly a
consistent schedule meaning i promised
you i would be here at 8 30 p.m
eastern time and i am here at 8 30 p.m
eastern time so that is a very very
exciting article and and much appreciate
the coverage from the wrap other super
oh wait did i have anything else
from the standpoint of memes i don't
think i did
um oh okay yeah an important message
if we get pulled for copyright now
c-span to me is relatively safe if one
of my streams gets pulled for copyright
check to see if the others have been
pulled okay because we we should i mean
hopefully we will get lucky
and at least one of the three streams
will persevere
it's twitch.tv david pakman
facebook.com davidpakmanshow and
youtube.com the davidpakman show
okay so let's hope let's hope none of
those uh none of those ugly things
happen
what else do we have here uh let's let's
listen in a little bit to see what's
going on
nothing is going on okay
all right and then let's listen in over
on pbs affordable care act will be on
the chopping block
all right this stream not going super
well for us so we will just mute that
and get back over to c-span
looks like there is some kind oh let's
listen to the admonishment of the
audience
my name is janet brown i'm executive
director of the commission on
presidential debates and i'd like to
welcome you to the first
presidential debate of 2020.
all right so she will admonish the
audience about proper behavior
uh and all of that stuff in the meantime
a few other super chats that i do want
to read 9000
ck says do you think trump will waddle
his way around the stage trying to
threaten biden
by the way your hair is looking schmick
today i don't know what schmick is i
hope it's not racist
i i think that there's a good chance if
it's not going well for trump
that he will try to do some of the
physical intimidation that he tried with
hillary clinton i'm more interested by
whether trump is going to pull
like as you guys know joe biden has
dealt with a stutter his entire life
if joe biden has a stutter is trump
going to try to call attention to it and
play it off like cognitive decline
and if trump does that if trump does
that
is joe biden going to be prepared with a
response one idea
i mentioned on today's bonus show we
were talking about this with producer
pat
is for biden to go back and say listen
this is a man
who for four years has been making fun
of everybody
he made fun of a disabled reporter
he's mocking me for a stutter something
which i have been dealing with for a
long time
go that right that would be one approach
for joe biden if
uh if if he wanted to come in with
something like that planned
much like much like kamala had a plan
for how to go after biden during one of
those early
democratic debates i don't know exactly
what biden's approach is going to be if
that happens but i'm certainly
certainly very curious to see
okay the glaive asks via super chat is
chris wallace the only thing in fox news
that has any semblance of journalistic
integrity left
yeah well since shep smith left
essentially yeah
i want to say thanks to the viking
vagabond for subscribing with twitch
prime as well as pupperoni's blue zeb
small fuzzy moss has subscribed with
prime
backer gang j spanx
shroom and a bunch of other really
really great people
um michael congratulates me on my great
coverage via super chat i appreciate
that
mabadee babbitty says i do hope this
shoddy mask requirement enforcement
becomes a story in the coming days how
is that okay
i don't understand how they have a
maskless event i mean some people in the
crowd were wearing masks
but many were not i truly don't
understand it i don't understand how
in this current circumstances you do
an indoor event with not with no mask
requirement it's absolutely ridiculous
absolutely absurd um
other super chats coming in oliver wilde
asks about debate bingo you know i
didn't do it
there's just so much going on and so
much to manage the debate hasn't we're
still 15 minutes from the debate
and we have 35 000 people watching live
right now
that i decided um that we are just going
to focus on the content we're going to
focus on the content once things uh
once things get going big thank you to
tesseraction uk who sends a powerful
super chat
says british supporter here not sure
i'll stay awake through this debate it
starts at 2am
but your coverage of politics has been
so refreshingly based
in reality not just accepting any claim
made either in the media or any live
interviews thank you thank you i very
much
appreciate that uh we are now only 12
minutes from the start of this debate i
do want to hear from you
super chat twitch subscriber messages
are great ways to
check in and and tell me that you're
here and that you have
something to say if you've been early
voting let me know
if you are all set with absentee let me
know i want to hear what everybody's
plan is
absentee but dropping off in person
would be interesting
uh that's that's probably my plan
um let's see what else we've got going
on
uh maria london has subscribed at
joinpakman.com and his new member number
11
sarah shippy is number 12 md west
is number 13. daniel nafis is number 14.
jeded brainiac is number 15. very much
appreciate that and of course we've got
a coupon code that's live and a lot of
really
exciting things going on there
uh pbs not yet picking up
the uh what's going on in the room i
would like to get
any number of streams though let me see
if i can just pick something
else up here let's see
um
okay uh wait a second where is that pbs
okay no it just seems pbs just has not
gone into the room yet which is fine
which is no problem at all uh okay
kyle hopper says tip mom for the setup
and hairstyling yeah i don't really live
with my mom that's it's just an ongoing
joke a lot of hatreds who write in
say you basement dwelling liberal loser
who lives with your mom blah blah blah
you know all that type of thing so i
play it up but it's not actually
not actually true um what else do we
have
big thank you to freedom jesus who's
being very generous on twitch
with gifted subscriptions which i very
much appreciate
sabrina's afar says did you hear about
the nearly hundred thousand defected
ballots sent out in new york city
defected
defective do you mean i have not heard
about that
um i will look into that though sabrina
and maybe you mean defective i'm not uh
i'm not totally totally sure on that
um e says david please don't talk over
the candidates thought you talked too
much over the dnc
save the comments for commercials love
the show since 2010.
okay i want to hear from you guys about
this do you want me to do
zero commentary whatsoever during the
debate
commentary if i can squeeze it in
without muting
or or pausing muted commentary or pause
commentary i don't like pause
because it extends it so much and then
we fall behind
live let me see what people say
some muted oh some people say that they
can't hear or see me i have no audio or
video right now
a lot of people saying they'll leave if
i don't talk oh my god
okay it seems like the light touch okay
yeah so here's what i'm going to do
um when when i sense brief pauses or
audience reaction and i can squeeze in a
little comment
i will do it just to give you a sense of
the general tenor of my analysis of what
i think is going on
but i'm not going to pause and i really
shouldn't mute if there's audience
noise i could you know just very softly
mute
momentarily and then uh maybe maybe
throw something in there but i will do
my best to do very very uh
little interruption of any kind of any
any time
kind joe's quadcopter videos
says my wife is watching for the first
time
she's hot well good for you and your
wife joe that's very exciting
um rv living life says
fox has 100 000 live viewers and pacman
has
30 000 that's impressive david yeah
we're hoping for the best stream ever
tonight
um right now we're at 42
and 32 is about 37 000
total i would like to get to 50. our
record
is um about 45 that's the best we've
ever done
from the perspective of of audience live
audience size
so we'll see we'll see how we do
um thank you to cindersole who says via
twitch
let's see the shaming of trump's taxes
begin yeah that's an interesting
question
you know the trump tax story is very
trump focused
so it could be perceived as um
as biased to talk about trump's taxes
but my instinct is that chris wallace
probably would be able
to frame it in a way that it applies to
both candidates
and uh we'll see we'll see i'm curious
to see how much uh
how much is mentioned during during the
debate
wallace derek says david you should talk
the entire time and mute the debate can
you imagine
that would be very disrespectful i think
ron collins says great job
keep it up strike boycott unify against
the corporate beast
more people coming out now it looks like
these are dignitaries from case western
reserve university which is hosting this
event
uh pbs still has not picked up the room
live but um we we presume that they will
very very soon
and we are now only seven minutes
okay this says 10 minutes okay but as
far as i know it's seven
let's see what else we've got other
people signing up on my website i
i set a very ambitious goal oh wait a
second what's going on with the twitch
subscription number
that's weird let me see if i can fix
that
what on earth happened here let me see
if i can fix that for you guys because
that's not looking too good
there we go okay all taken care of i
really don't know what happened there um
people are signing up at joinpakman.com
i love the show of support
kate ahrens is new member number 16
and um georgina egger is number 17.
john noble is number 18. ryan smith is
number 19.
karsten crowe simonson is number 20.
sarah ventura is number 21.
uh the bar will will remain active
throughout the debate as we are now just
minutes away from the first debate
here between donald trump and joe biden
um other super chats that are
interesting that are coming in
geodude says i'm here to watch the
debate and hear from my argentine pal
if peeps don't want to hear you they can
go watch elsewhere elsewhere keep it up
edemano
i have very by the way i have an
exciting announcement coming later this
week
about spanish language content okay i
think a lot of people
are really going to like it really
really going to like it
um hazel angus says i hope biden doesn't
focus on taxes too much he needs to sell
himself
as himself rather than just pushing i'm
not trump
i think that makes sense i think that's
a very very good idea
rocco thompson says so glad we have you
david to look very strongly at this
debate from the standpoint of
arguments well said i'm looking forward
to the exact same thing
um sam keller says how do you think
biden will fare with trump's
aggressiveness and domineering
personality
we'll know in 10 minutes i don't even
need to venture a guess we're going to
know in 10 minutes
rhetorical oracle asks whether i think
they'll be on stimulants tonight
no comment let's just wait and see at
this point
there is no need for speculation no need
whatsoever for speculation robbery says
via twitch prime please do commentary
during the debate if i wanted no
interruptions i would watch another
stream
that's aggressive that's aggressive
a funeral says most views goes to you
and counter
i don't know what that means funeral i
really don't
a jerome sir cruz director says as trump
asks for drug test
why biden doesn't ask for fact check
biden did ask for live fact checking
actually
uh i'll have to do what i can to help
you guys
uh with live fact checking i don't i
don't think we're i don't know that
we're going to get it from uh from from
chris wallace
thank you to captain crunch for the
twitch prime subscription
picks the god appreciate that as well
um we are very very close to the start
of this debate and i am
welcoming everybody here the the debate
scheduled to start
officially at 9 00 pm eastern but
looking at the timer at the bottom of
the screen i guess it's going to be more
like 904
we believe that pbs will eventually go
over to the debate live
as well um
super chats continue to come in albix
rouroni says david glad to see you
pushing spanish content in my opinion
they are the least informed in our
country that that's that's not true
that's uh that that's actually
horrifying to say
michael riscotti says what do you
recommend ordering at michael's deli in
brookline my friend and i are ready to
pig out david we simp for you and your
food recommendations yes go in and tell
steve
at uh michael's deli that david pakman
sent you
i would highly recommend here's what i
would do
i would get a pastrami on on
pumpernickel with mustard while you're
there as the trump family lumbers in
i would get a pastrami on rye with
mustard while you're there and get some
corned beef to go
get some knishes to go spinach i believe
is probably the best then get some
potato sometimes he has an actual
it's under the the umbrella of crazy
canisius
he has a pastrami canish highly
recommended
and uh definitely get some of the
pickles and
um maybe some whitefish salad that's
that's what i think would be a really
great uh nice order
uh at michael's deli and remember it's
cash or venmo only
cash or venmo only okay chris wallace is
here we are about to turn this over
listen
my one request to you guys is get a
membership on my website okay
we might run out of memberships today if
you can imagine
but go to joinpakman.com we're talking
two bucks a month if you use the coupon
code above
my head 2020 now uh that's our primary
funding source
okay 21 people have signed up
i think we could break 150 theoretically
today
we've quadrupled the resources of our
website
to be able to handle the traffic tonight
i dare you to try to overwhelm the
website with new memberships
but we may have to we may run out of
subscriptions tonight
that's the crazy crazy thing and let's
get
now to chris wallace introducing some of
these elements of the debate
and we have no audio here from chris
wallace how is that possible
oh because it's not playing nope we
still have no all right good this is why
we start early this is just
uh to be able to get everything set up
correctly
why can't we hear chris wallace
i don't know let's see if it's a browser
issue
it seems to be
all right not a problem we have
any number of different things that we
can fix here
uh default here we go
program continues in a oh now this is
this is muted
why don't we have any audio this is very
strange
it's the source oh okay okay okay
there's no oh oh
oh oh they are not um i see what you're
saying they are not transmitting the
audio okay
i just got really really scared hold on
let me see if i can get it in another
browser
no okay there's no audio in any browser
got it got it got it got it
all right so just to now there's audio
what's going on here
he doesn't have it i i want to make sure
that if this is uh
same on the cable feed no audio in
austria
you know what i'm going to do i'm just
going to check if uh
let me just see if like for example i
can get the plasma song
today i'm pleased to okay all right all
right all right that makes me less
concerned so it does appear to be the
feed
there's no audio anywhere i just got
very scared my friends
we almost had a very very powerful ah
here we go
okay endemic only about 80 people will
be in the audience
okay uh there is melania trump
i think is that who that is yes okay
melania trump there
um and a lot a lot going on here
as we get very close to the start of
this debate okay uh
members i see you all karen stewart is
new member number 22.
ryan collins 23 robert disha 24 we will
update we
while the debate is going we will update
the bar okay so nobody worry about that
all memberships will be credited and
let's hope that we do not run
out of such memberships william benbrook
says biden should volunteer a urine test
that trump can collect yeah trump seems
focused on urine it's really bizarre
really really bizarre uh
destination says get a beer and chill we
will wait for you all right well
thank you hunter white says fyi i
subscribed but didn't hear if you got it
we're going to work through the list
we're going to work through the list
because there's a lot of stuff backed up
jacob parise as asking whether he should
order pizza
and chinese food i would probably just
go with a pizza tonight
that's my sense maybe maybe for the vp
debate go with chinese food
i uh i don't i don't think that that's a
bad idea
thanks to ramekinbeast who has
subscribed with prime and says thanks a
lot for everything you do
keep it up thank you a thanks to just
the fluffy panda
t-vone t-bone vargos
catch catch-ow bravo mania jack
sablush gazix araddens
geez these are some difficult names
throw some vowels in there
um all right very good
uh what else do we have going on yeah no
people worried about the audio the audio
actually is okay
as you can see here the subtitles say
silence so that's what tells us that the
audio is correct
and um pbs not even in the room yet
we are tentatively one minute from the
start of the first
presidential debate i'm so glad that you
were with us we do now have
47 000 people watching across all
platforms
and it could not be a greater day that
does set a record for us for a live
stream
we've never had 47 000 people watching
at once
and we in theory will get
uh the few the other two presidential
and vp debates so if you want to be
notified about those
if you're watching me on uh youtube
make sure to hit that subscribe button
it's absolutely free if you're watching
on twitch
go ahead and follow let's get to chris
wallace apparently
just about ready to start here prompter
is ready to go
still silence
still silence they said trump is running
that are you serious trump is running
late for a debate that cannot be
what this i mean maybe he's having a
medical issue
maybe you know maybe it's uh you know
substance who knows maybe
if we see upper trump come out strongly
you know you know what i'm talking about
you know what i'm talking about
chris wallace continuing to wait uh
giving the one minute signal as you can
see
oh now chris wahl's talking answers from
health education campus of case western
reserve university
and the cleveland clinic we're off and
running i'm chris wallace of fox news
and i welcome you to the first of the
2020 presidential debates
between president donald j trump and
former vice president joe biden
let's actually go with the pbs that's my
last change
date is being conducted under health and
safety protocols designed by the
cleveland clinic
which is serving as the health security
advisor to the commission for all four
debates
as a precaution both campaigns have
agreed the candidates
will not shake hands at the beginning of
tonight's debate perfect
the audience here in the hall has
promised to remain silent no cheers
no booze or other interruptions so we
and more importantly you
can focus on what the candidates have to
say
no noise except right now as we welcome
the republican nominee president trump
and the democratic nominee vice
president biden here we go ladies and
gentlemen these two men on stage
together for the first time in this
campaign
how you doing man says joe biden
gentlemen a lot of people have been
waiting for
this night so let's get going our first
subject is the supreme court
president trump you nominated amy coney
barrett over the weekend
to succeed the late ruth bader ginsburg
on the court
you say the constitution is clear about
your obligation and the senate's
to consider a nominee to the court vice
president biden you say that this is an
effort by the president and republicans
to jam through an appointment and what
you call
an abuse of power my first question to
both of you tonight
why are you right in the argument you
make
and your opponent wrong and where do you
think
a justice barrett would take the court
here we go
president trump in this first segment
you go first two minutes
thank you very much chris i will tell
you very simply we won the election
elections have consequences we have the
senate
we have the white house and we have a
phenomenal
nominee respected by all top top
academic uh good in every way good in
every way
lie in fact some of her biggest
endorsers
are very liberal people from notre dame
and other places so i think she's going
to be fantastic we have plenty of time
even if we did it after the election
itself i have a lot of time after the
election as you know
so i think that she will be outstanding
she's going to be
as good as anybody that has served on
that court we really feel that
we have a professor at notre dame highly
respected by all said she's the single
greatest
student he's ever had he's petering
outside for a long time at a great
school
and uh we just uh we won the election
and therefore we have the right
to choose her and very few people
knowingly
would say otherwise and by the way the
democrats they wouldn't even think about
not doing it if they had the only
difference is they'd try and do it
faster
there's no way they would give it up
they had merit garland but the problem
is they didn't have the election so
they were stopped and probably that
would happen
in reverse also definitely would happen
in reverse so we won the election and we
have the right to do it chris
president trump thank you um same
question to you vice president biden you
have
two minutes well first of all um
thank you for doing this and looking
forward to this mr president i
uh the american people have a right
to have a say in who the supreme court
nominee is and that say
occurs when they vote for a united
states senators
and when they vote for the president
united states they're not going to get
that chance now because we're in the
middle of an election already
election has already started tens of
thousands of people have already voted
and so the thing that should happen is
we should wait
we should wait and see what the outcome
of this election is because that's the
only way the american people get to
express
their view is by who they elect as
president and who they elect as vice
president
now what's at stake here is the
president's made it clear
he wants to get rid of the affordable
care act he's been running on that
he ran on that and he's yeah exactly
right
he's in the supreme court right now
trying to get rid of uh
the the affordable care act which uh
will strip
20 million people from having
insurance health insurance now this is
the issue this is the court
and and uh the justice and i have
nothing i'm not opposed to the justices
she seems like a very fine person but
she's written before she went in the
bench which is her right
that she thinks that the affordable care
act is not constitutional
the other thing is on the court and if
it's struck down what happens
women's rights are fundamentally changed
once again
a woman could be held a bit of a stumble
money because she has a pre-existing
condition of pregnancy
strong people they were able to charge
women delivering the same exact
procedure a man did
gets and that ended when we in fact
passed the affordable care act and
there's a hundred million people have
pre-existing conditions
and they'll be taken away as well those
pre-existing conditions
insurance companies are going to love
this and so it's just not appropriate
to do this before this election if he
wins
the election and the senate is democrat
a republican
then he goes forward if not we should
wait until february first half
100 million people with pre-existing as
far as the say
is concerned the people already had
their say they
okay justice ginsburg said very powerful
at some point ten years ago or so
she said a president and the senate is
elected for a period of time the
president is elected for four years
we're not elected for three years i'm
not elected for three years what about
obama so we have the senate we have a
president
elected to the next during that period
of time during that period of time
we have an opening i'm not elected
100 million people is totally wrong i
don't know where you got that number
the bigger problem that you have is that
you're going to
extinguish 180 million people with their
private health care that they're very
completely untrue well you said
you're going to socialism
there it is gentlemen we're now into
open discussions
yes i agree go ahead vice president
number one uh
he he knows that uh what i proposed what
i proposed is that uh
we expand obamacare and we increase it
we do not
wipe any and one of the big debates we
had with 23
of my colleagues trying to win the
nomination that i won we're saying that
biden wanted to
allow people to have private insurance
still they can
they do they will under my proposal what
you've said right and it's not what that
party is saying that is simply the party
doesn't say your party wants to go
socialist
wrong party is the socialist right now
there's nothing
they're gonna dominate you joe you know
that i am the democratic party right now
the platform of the democratic party is
what i
in fact approved of what i approved of
now here's the deal the deal is that
it's going to wipe out
pre-existing conditions and by the way
the 20 the 200 million the 200 000
people that have died on his watch
they're how many of those and have
survived well there's seven million
people that contracted covet what does
it mean for them
going forward if you strike down the
affordable care act correctly joe you've
had
308 years interrupted military people
dying because you
will provide them proper health care in
the military so don't tell me about
happy to talk about
and if you were here you wouldn't be 200
it would be two million people
because you were very late on the draw
you didn't want me to ban china
which was heavily infected china all
right
gentlemen
we are going to talk about covet in the
next segment but go ahead
let me finish the point is that the
president also
is opposed to roe v wade that's on the
ballot as well
in the court in the court and so that's
also at stake
right now and so the election is all you
don't know it's on the ballot
why is it in the ballot because
it's not on the ballot it's on the
ballot in the court i think so in the
court
well there's nothing happening there
donald would you just want to know
her view on roe v wade i don't know
yes she stated all right let's talk she
stated it
we've got a lot to unpack here gentlemen
we've got a lot of time so
this is healthcare and then we'll come
back to roe v
wade all right mr president the supreme
court will hear
a case a week after the election in
which the trump administration along
with 18 state attorneys general
are seeking to overturn that's right
obamacare
obamacare you have spent the last
because they want to give good
healthcare
he can't even ask a question good health
care over
uh the last four years you have promised
to repeal
and replace obamacare but you have never
in these four years
come up with a plan a comprehensive plan
replace obamacare
that is absolutely a big thing that was
the worst part of obamacare
christmas let me ask
and i would like you to let me ask my
question and then you can answer
you in the course of these four years
have never come up with a comprehensive
plan
to replace obamacare and
just this last thursday you signed a
largely symbolic executive order to
protect people
with pre-existing conditions five days
before this debate
so my question sir is what is the trump
health care plan
well first of all i guess i'm debating
you not him but that's okay i'm not
surprised let me just tell you something
there's nothing symbolic i'm cutting
drug prices i'm going with favored
nations which no president has the
courage to do because you're going
against big pharma
drug prices will be coming down 80 or 90
you could have done it during your
47-year period in government but you
didn't do it
nobody's done it so we're cutting health
care what about all of the things that
we've done
yeah right now i've given you an example
insulin it's going to it was destroying
families destroying people the cause
i'm getting it for so cheap it's like
water you want to know the truth
so cheap take a look at all of the drugs
that what we're doing prescription drug
prices
we're going to allow our governors now
to go to other countries to buy
drugs because they pay just
sir you'll be happy i'm about to pick up
on one of your points
to ask the vice president which is he
points out that you would like to add a
public
option to obamacare yes the argument
that he makes and other republicans make
is that that is going to end private
insurance it is and well
if i ask you the question it's not it
well your party says by the way it will
end
private insurance and create a
government takeover of healthcare it
does not it's only for those people who
are so
poor they qualify for medicaid
they can get that free in most states
except governors who want to deny
people or poor medicaid that's right
anyone who qualifies for medicare would
me excuse me medicaid would
automatically be enrolled in the public
option
the vast majority of the american people
would still not
be obviously that option number one you
the fact of the matter is i beat bernie
sanders they got to cut his number how
much
i beat him a whole hell of a lot i'm
here i'm here standing facing you
hunters would have left two days early
you would have lost every price oh he
knows how to do super tuesday you got to
look very lucky there's a deal
i got very luck gaming very lucky
tonight as well and tonight i'm going to
make sure
because what does it do here's the deal
the fact is that everything he's saying
so far
is simply a lie i'm not here to call out
his lies everybody knows he's a liar but
you i just want him to
tell you that i i i i want to make sure
can you let him finish sir no he doesn't
know how to do that he has
you know christ you picked to be
surprised the wrong guy the wrong night
at the wrong time listen you agreed with
him
sandersonville
number two you just lost the left
you agreed with bernie sanders on a plan
absolutely
mr president tell you what he is not for
any help for people needing health care
because his because he in fact already
has cost 10 million people their health
care that they had from their employers
because of his recession number one
number two
there are 20 million people getting
health care through obamacare now
that he wants to take it away he won't
ever look in eye and say that's what he
wants to do
take it away oh i want to give numbers
better health care at a much lower price
because
he doesn't know how he doesn't know how
he's already fixed it he has never
offered to fix it except he
obamacare is no good we made it better
and i had a choice to make very early on
we took away the individual mandate we
guarantee pre-existing conditions but
took away the individual mandate
listen this is the way it is and that
destroyed
that they shouldn't even call it
obamacare then i had a choice to make do
i let my people run it really well
or badly trust me they'll probably blame
him but they'll blame me but more
importantly i want to help people
okay i said you're going to run it so
well that's it and i just had a meeting
with them they said the problem is no
matter how well
we run obamacare it's a disaster it's
too expensive
premiums are too high that it doesn't
work ourselves
we do want to get rid of it we want to
get rid of that i understand that
but i have to i have to give you roughly
equal time please
let the vice president talk he has no
plan for health care correct yes we do
sends plays
he sends out wishful thinking he has
executive orders that have no power he
hasn't lowered drug costs for anybody
he's correct promising a health care
plan
since he got elected he has none like
almost everything
else he talks about he does not have a
plan
he doesn't have a plan and the fact is
this man doesn't know what he's talking
about correct
i have one final question for you sure
uh mr vice president
if senate republicans we were talking
originally about the supreme court here
if senate republicans go ahead and
confirm
justice barrett uh there has been talk
about ending the filibuster
or even packing the court adding to the
nine justices there
you call this a distraction by the
president but in fact it wasn't brought
up by the president
it was brought up by some of your
democratic colleagues in i'm saying the
congress
so my question to you is you have
refused in the past to talk about it
are you willing to tell the american
people tonight whether or not you will
support
either ending the filibuster or packing
the court whatever position i take in
that that'll become the issue the cause
she is the american people should speak
you should go out and vote you're in
voting now
vote and let your senators know how
strong you feel
let vote now make sure
i'm not going to answer the question
because you answered that because the
question is
the question is justice radical left
would you
listen who is on your list joe this is
yours
gentlemen i think
we're going to move on to the second
segment that was really a productive
segment wasn't it
keep yapping man the people understand
yeah
all right the second subject is coveted
19 which is an awfully serious subject
oh my god let's try to be serious about
it we have had
more than seven million cases of
coronavirus
in the united states and more than two
hundred thousand people
well i did great they died even we're
doing we produce
a vaccine experts say that it could be
months or even years
before we come back to anything
approaching
normal my question for both of you is
based on what you have said
and done so far and what you have said
you would do
starting in 2021 why should the american
people
trust you more than your opponent
to deal with this public health crisis
going forward
in this case the question goes to you
first sir
two minutes uninterrupted perfect good
luck
two hundred thousand dead as you said
over seven million infected in the
united states
we in fact have five percent or four
percent of the world's population
twenty percent of the deaths forty
thousand people
a day are contracting covet correct in
addition to that
about between 750 and a thousand people
today are dying
when he was presented with that number
he said it is what it is
correct well it is what it is because
you are who you are
that's why it is the president has no
plan he hasn't laid out anything he knew
all the way back in february how serious
this crisis was
he knew it was a deadly disease what did
he do
he's on tape is acknowledging he knew it
he said he didn't tell us or give people
a warning of it
because he didn't want to panic the
american people you don't panic
he panicked in addition to that what did
he do
he went in and he we were insisting that
the chinese
the people we had on the ground in china
should be able to go to wuhan
and determine for themselves how
dangerous this was
he did not even ask she to do that he
told us what a great job
she was doing he said we owe him a debt
of gratitude
for being so transparent with us and
what did he do then
he then did nothing he waited and waited
and waited he still doesn't have a plan
i laid out back in march exactly what we
should be doing
and i laid out again in july what we
should be doing
we should be providing all the
protective gear possible we should be
providing the money the house has passed
in order to be able to go out and get
people the help they need to keep their
businesses open
open schools that cost a lot of money
you should get out of your bunker and
get out of the sand trap and get
in in your golf course and go in the
oval office and bring together the
democrats and republicans
and fund what needs to be done now to
save lives
so if we would have listened to you you
have two minutes sir
if we would have listened to you oh the
country would have been left wide open
millions of people would have died not
two hundred 000 and one person is too
much it's
china's fault it should have never
happened they stopped it from going in
but it was china's fault
and by the way when you talk about
numbers you don't know how many people
died in china
you don't know how many people died in
russia you don't know how many people
died in india they don't exactly give
you a straight question
but if you look at what we've done i
closed it and you said he's xenophobic
he's a racist and he's xenophobic
because you didn't think i should have
closed our country wait a minute says
two minutes you didn't think we should
have closed our country
because you thought it was too it was
terrible you wouldn't have closed it for
another two months
by my doing it early in fact dr fauci
said president trump
saved thousands of lives many of your
democrat governor said
president trump did a phenomenal job we
worked with the governor oh really go
take a look
the governor said i did a phenomenal job
most of them said that
in fact people that would not be
necessarily on my side
said that president trump did a
phenomenal job
we did we got the gowns we got the masks
we made the ventilators you wouldn't
have made ventilators and now we're
weeks away from a vaccine
why wouldn't we doing therapeutics
already fewer people are dying when they
get
sick far fewer people are dying we've
done a great job
the only thing i haven't done a good job
and that's because of the fake news
no matter what you say to them they give
you a bad press on it's just fake news
they give you good press they give me
bad press because that's the way it is
unfortunately but let me just tell you
something i don't care i've gotten used
to it
but i'll tell you joe you could never
have done the job that we did you don't
have it in your home you could have
never done that yet
i know how to do the job i know how to
get the job well you didn't do very well
in swine flu
h1n1 you were a disaster your own
personality
14 000 people died not two hundred
thousand there was no
economic recession you made a period
you and there was no one there's no we
didn't shut down the economy
this is his economy that's being he shut
down the reason it's shut down is
because
look you folks at home how many of you
get up this morning
and had an empty chair at the kitchen
table because someone died of covet
how many of you were in a situation
where you lost your mom or dad and you
couldn't even speak to the
nurse holding a phone up so you could in
fact say goodbye you would have lost
father how many people
wrong more people
his own cdc director says we could lose
as many as another
200 000 people between now and the end
of the year and he held them he said
if we just wear a mask we can save half
those numbers just just to mask
and by the way in terms of the the whole
notion of a vaccine
we're for a vaccine but we i don't trust
him at all nor do you i know you don't
what we trust is a scientist correct
johnson
questions about the future because you
both have touched on one of the two of
the questions i'm going to ask uh
focusing on the future first president
trump you have repeatedly
either contradicted or been at odds with
some of your government's own top
scientists the week before last
the head of the centers for disease
control dr redfield said it would be
summer before the vaccine would become
generally available to the public you
said that he was confused
and mistaken those are your two words
but
dr slowly the head of your operation
workspeed
has said exactly the same thing are they
both wrong well i've spoken to the
companies and we can have it a lot
sooner it's a very political thing
because people like this
would rather make it political than save
lives is a very political thing
i've spoken to pfizer i've spoken to all
of the people that you have to speak to
we have great
moderna johnson and johnson and others
they can go faster than that by a lot
become very political because the left
or i don't know
what the head of your operation warp
speed doctor i disagree with him yeah no
i disagree with both of them
and he didn't say that he said it could
be there but it could also be much you
know
i had him in my office two days he
talked about the summer sir before it's
generally available
she said it's a possibility guys who are
you going to trust doctors or this dude
before november 1st it could also be
everything
available well we're going to deliver it
right away we have the military all set
up logistically they're all set up
we have our military that delivers
soldiers and they can do 200 000 a day
they're going to be disagreeing with the
this would be gone away by the warm
weather it'd be gone
miraculous like a miracle and by the way
maybe you could inject some bleach in
your arm and yeah take care of it
this is sarcastic always said sarcasm
so here's the deal this man is talking
about a vaccine
every serious every serious company is
talking about
maybe having a vaccine done by the end
of the year but the distribution of that
vaccine
will not occur until sometime beginning
or the middle of next year to get it out
if we get the vaccine and pray god we
will
may god mr vice president i want to pick
up though you'll have the vaccine
i want to pick up on this question
though you say the public
can trust the scientists but they can't
trust president trump in fact you said
that again tonight correct your running
mate senator harris goes further
saying the public health experts quote
will be muzzled
will be suppressed given the fact that
polls already
show that people are concerned about the
vaccine and are reluctant to take it
are you and your running mate senator
harris contributing to that fear
no more than the question you just asked
him you pointed out
that's right puts pressure and disagrees
with his own
scientist but you're saying you can't
you know harris is saying you can't
trust the side
well no no you can't trust the scientist
he said she didn't say that you can't
she said the public health experts will
be muzzled
will be surprised she said she won't
trust it on trump say so
there's thousands of scientists out
there like here at this great hospital
that don't work for him their job
doesn't depend on him
that's not they're the people they're
and by the way
to the scientists that are in charge by
the way they will have the vaccine very
soon
do you believe for a moment what he's
telling you in light of all the lies
he's told you
about the whole issue relating to covet
he still hasn't even acknowledged that
he knew
this was happening knew how dangerous
was going to be
back in february and he didn't even tell
you
he's on record as saying it he panicked
or he just looked at the stock market
one of the two
because guess what a lot of people died
and a lot more going to die unless he
gets a lot smarter a lot quicker
did you use the word smart yes uh so you
said you went to delaware
state but you forgot the name of your
college uh-oh you didn't go to delaware
state you graduated
either the lowest or almost the lowest
in your class don't use the word smart
with me
don't ever use that word oh give me your
because you know what there's nothing
smart about you joe 47 years you've done
this let's add this to ben
you would have had let me just tell you
something oh my god if you would have
had
bring up s.a.t tests of what i was put
through i had to close
the greatest economy in the history of
our country and by the way now it's
being
built again you see we're going to get
to the economy in the next segment sir
okay it's going up fast okay when it
comes to how
the virus has been handled so far the
two of you have taken very different
approaches and this is going to affect
how the virus
is handled going forward by whichever of
you ends up becoming the next president
i want to quickly go through several of
those reopenings
vice president biden you have been much
more reluctant than president trump
about reopening the economy and schools
why sir
because he doesn't have a plan if i were
running i know how what the plan is
you've got to provide these businesses
the ability to have the money to be able
to reopen with the ppe
as well as with the sanitation they need
you have to provide them
pelosi oh come on well he's just shush
for a minute
tell it and humor by the way chuck
pelosi and schumer they have a plan he
won't even meet with him that's right
the republicans won't meet with the
senate
but he and he sits he sits in his golf
course and
i mean literally think about it you
probably played more than i do joe
what about this question of reopenings
and the fact he wants to shut down this
country no i don't know and i want to
keep it open and we did it
shut it down wait a minute let me shut
you down for a second joe just for one
second
we want to he wants to shut down the
country we just went through it we had
to because we didn't know anything about
the disease now we found
that elderly people with heart problems
and diabetes and different problems are
very very vulnerable we learned a lot
young children aren't
uh even younger people aren't we've
learned a lot but he wants to shut it
down
more people will be heard by continuing
if you look at pennsylvania if you look
at certain states
that have been shut down they have
democrat governors all one of the
reasons they shut down is because they
want to keep it shut down until after
the election
but those states those states are not
doing well that are shut down
responding you have begun
to increasingly question the
effectiveness
of masks as a disease preventer and in
fact recently you have cited the
the issue of of waiters touching their
mass and touching plates
are you questioning
you have to them if you look i mean i
have a mask right here i prop a mask on
it you know when i think i need it
tonight as an example everybody's had a
test and you've had
social distancing and all of the things
that you have to but i wear masks when
needed
when needed i wear a mask okay let me
ask i don't have i don't wear mess like
him every time you see him he's got a
mask he could be speaking
200 feet away from it he shows up with
the biggest mask i've ever seen
imagine vice president
that's a bad idea yeah the way to open
businesses
is give them the wherewithal to be able
open we provided money
the kind of i was asking a sir about
masks well mask masks make a big
difference his own
head of cdc said if we just wore mass
between now
if there everybody wore a mask in social
distance between now and january
we'd probably save up to a hundred
thousand lives
it matters and they've also seen the
opposite they've also said no
no serious person said the opposite they
know
subject because your different
approaches has even affected the way
that you have campaigned
president trump you're holding large
rallies with crowds packed together
thousands of people outside yes sir
agreed
uh vice president biden you are holding
much smaller uh
events with nobody will show up people
with math
what's true nobody should just all right
in any case
why you holding the big rallies why you
not
you goes first sir because people want
to hear what i have to say i mean but
are you not worried about great job
and i'll have 25 35 000 people show up
at airports
he doesn't have 30 reports we have a lot
of people
well so far we have had no problem
whatsoever it's outside that's a big
difference according to the
experts and we do them outside we have
tremendous
crowds as you see i mean every and and
literally on 24 hours notice
and joe does the circles and has three
people someplace okay by the way did you
just
did you one of the last big rallies he
had and a reporter came up to him to ask
him a question he said no no no
stand back put on your mask put on a
mask
have you been tested i'm way i'm way far
away from those other people
that's what he said i can't i'm going to
be okay he's not worried about you
he's not worried about the people out
there breathing in one another we've had
no negativity
no negative effect we've had no negative
effect and we've had
35 40 thousand people who hasn't had
thirty five just quickly finish up
because i wanna move on to our next yes
i would he's been totally irresponsible
the way in which he has handled
the social distancing and people wearing
masks basically encourage them not to
all right then he's a fool if you could
get the crowds
you would have done the same thing but
you can't nobody can gentlemen can we
move on to the accusers gentlemen can we
move on to the economy yes
the economy is i think it's fair to say
recovering
faster than expected from the shutdown
in the second quarter the unemployment
rate fell to 8.4
last month the federal reserve says the
hit
to growth which is going to be there is
not going to be nearly as big
as they had expected president trump you
say we
are in a v-shaped recovery
vice president biden you say it's more
of a k-shape
what difference does that mean to
the american people in terms of the
economy president trump in this
segment you go first so we built the
greatest economy in history we closed it
down because of the china plague when
the plague came in we closed it down
which was very hard
psychologically to do he didn't think we
should close it down and he was wrong
and again 2 million people would be dead
now instead of
still 204 000 people is too much
one person is too much should have never
happened from china
but what happened is we closed it down
and now we're reopening and we're doing
record business
we had 10.4 million people in a
four-month period that we've
put back into the workforce that's a
record the likes of which nobody's ever
seen before
and he wants to close down the he will
shut it down again he will destroy this
country
you know a lot of people between drugs
and alcohol and
depression when you start shutting it
down you take a look at what's happening
at some of your democrat-run states
where they have these
tough shutdowns and i'm telling you it's
because they don't want to open it one
of them came out
last week you saw that oh we're going to
open up on november 9th why november 9th
because it's after the election
they think they're hurting us by keeping
them closed they're hurting people
people know what to do they can social
distance they can wash their hands they
can wear masks
they can do whatever they want but they
got to open these states up
when you look at north carolina you look
and these governors are under siege
pennsylvania michigan and a couple of
others
you've got to open these states up it's
not fair you're talking about almost
it's like being in prison and you look
at what's going on with divorce
look at what's going on with alcoholism
and drugs it's a very very sad thing
and he'll close down the whole country
this guy will close down the whole
country
and destroy our country our country is
coming back incredibly well
setting records as it does it we don't
need somebody to come in and say let's
shut it down
oh it's prison you're two minutes sir
we're now moved to you
as i as i said posing the question the
president says it's a v-shape recovery
you say it's a k-shaped
recovery what's the difference the
difference is
millionaires and billionaires like him
in the middle of the cover crisis
supposedly right had done very well
another billionaires of ray have made
another 300
billion dollars because of his
profligate tax
proposal and he only focused on the
market but you folks at home
you folks living in scranton and
claymont and all the small towns and
working-class towns in america
how old are you doing this guy paid well
total of 750 dollars in taxes
wait wait no hold on i understand you've
agreed to the two minutes so please let
him have it if i get my time back
the fact is that he has in fact worked
on this in a way that he's going to be
the first president united states
to leave office having fewer jobs in his
administration
than when he became president fewer jobs
than when he became friends first one in
american history
secondly the people who have lost their
jobs
are those people who have been on the
front lines those people who have been
saving our lives those people who have
been out there
dying people who've been putting
themselves in the way to make sure
that we could all try to make it and the
idea that he is
insisting that we go forward and open
when you have almost half the states in
america with a significant increase
in covert deaths and covert cases in the
united states america
and he wants to open it up more why does
he want to open it up why doesn't he
take care of the america
you can't fix the economy until you fix
the covet crisis
and he has no intention of doing
anything about making it better
for you all at home in terms of your
health and your safety
schools why aren't schools open because
it costs a lot of money to open them
safely
you know they were going to give his
administration going to give the
teachers and school
students mask and then they decided no
couldn't do that because it's not a
national emergency
not a national emergency they've done
nothing to help
small businesses nothing they're closing
one in six is now gone
he ought to get on the job and take care
of the needs of the american people
so we can't open safe right your time is
up sir we are going to get to
i have to respond to that well you both
had two minutes sir
excuse me he made a statement people
wanted
no people want their school chris
wallace should be able to cut
one of their mics when the other is
talking you you have to have that with
trump
so sad what's happening in new york it's
almost like a ghost town
and i'm not sure it can ever recover
what they've done in new york
people want their places open they want
to get back to their lives people
they'll be careful but they want their
schools
i'm the one that brought back football
by the way i brought back big 10
football
football it was me and i'm very happy to
do it
and all right people of ohio are very
proud of me and
you're not going to get about that we're
going to get to your
economic plans going forward in a moment
but first mr president
as you well know there's a new report
that in 2016 the year you were elected
here we go
in 2017 here we go your first year as
president that you paid
750 a year in federal
income tax each of those years
i know that you pay a lot of other taxes
but i'm asking you the specific question
is it true that you paid 750 in federal
income taxes each of those two years i
paid millions of dollars in taxes
millions of dollars
of income tax and let me just tell you
there was a story in one of the papers
i paid 38 million dollars one year
i paid 27 million
i went uh you'll see it as soon as it's
finished you'll see it you know what i
want to do
go to the board of elections there's a
118 page or so report
that says everything i have every bank i
have i'm totally
under leveraged because the assets are
extremely good
and we have a very we have a i built
that i'm asking you a specific question
which is
let me tell you i understand all of that
no mr president i'm asking you a
question
will you tell us how much you paid in
federal income taxes
in 20 2016 and 2017. millions of dollars
you paid millions of dollars millions of
dollars millions of dollars and you get
to see it
and you'll get to see it but let me show
you now the new york times has to
publish the documents
it was the tax laws i don't want to pay
tax beca before i came here
i was a private developer i was a
private business people
like every other private person unless
they're stupid
they go through the laws and that's what
it is he passed a tax bill
that gave us all these privileges for
depreciation
and for trump tax credits we build the
building and we get tax credits like the
hotel
on pennsylvania avenue you get a massive
which by the way was given to me
by the obama administration if you can
believe that
now the men got fired right after that
happened but vice president biden you
want to respond yeah i do want to
respond
look the tax code that made him
put him in a position that he pays less
tax than a school teacher
make them on the money a school teacher
makes is because
of him take he says he's smart because
he can take advantage of the tax code
and he does take advantage of the tax
code that's why i'm going to eliminate
the trump tax cuts
and we're gonna we're gonna eliminate
those taxes and make sure that we invest
in the people who in fact
need the help people out there need help
but why didn't you do it over
the last 25 years
in 47 months i've done more than you've
done in 47 years
we've done things that you never even
thought about okay fixing the broken
military that you gave me
the reason he didn't think of them is
because they're terrible ideas talking
about the economy i'd like to ask you
about your plans going forward because
uh mr vice president your economic plan
if you were to be elected president uh
focuses a lot on big government big
taxes
big spending i want to focus first on
the taxes
you proposed more than four trillion
dollars over a decade and new taxes
on individuals making more than 400 000
a year and on corporations president
trump says that that kind of an
increase in taxes is going to hurt the
economy as it's just coming out of a
recession
just take the analysis has been on by
wall street firms
points out that my my economic plan
would create seven million more jobs in
his in four years number one
and number two it would create an
additional one trillion dollars in
economic growth because it would be
about
buying american that we have to we're
going to make this federal government
spend 600 billion dollars here on
everything from
ships to steel to buildings and the like
and under my proposal we're going to
make sure that every penny of that
has to be made by a company respectfully
so i'm talking about taxes not spending
well
by the way i'm going to eliminate a
significant number of the tax i'm going
to make the the
the corporate tax 28 it shouldn't be 21
you have 19 companies 91 companies
federal i mean in the fortune 500 who
don't pay a single penny in tax making
billions of dollars
because you in fact passed that that was
your
tax proposal you got it done and you
know what happened yeah you got it down
our economy boom
like it's never boom let me finish
mr president let me pick up on that you
would continue
your free market approach lower taxes
more
deregulation correct not lower taxes
american people
let me excuse me but talk about trump in
obama's you talk about the economy
booming
it turns out that in obama's final three
years as president
uh-oh more jobs were created a million
and a half more jobs
than in the first three years of your
presidency the slowest
recovery since night economic recovery
since 1929
it was the slowest recovery also they
took over something that was down here
all you had to do was turn on the lights
and you pick up a lot
but they had the slowest economic
recovery since 1929 let me tell you
about the stock market
when the stock market goes up that means
jobs it also means 401ks
if you got in if you ever became
president with your ideas you want to
terminate my tax
my taxes i i'll tell you what you'll
lose half of the companies that have
poured in here
will leave and plenty of companies that
are already here they'll leave from
other places have
they will leave and you will have a
depression the likes of which
you've never seen what companies we
inherited
the worst recession short of a
depression in american history
i was asked to bring it back we were
able to have an economic recovery that
created the jobs you're talking about
we handed him a booming economy he blew
it it wasn't he flew it
wasn't booming job growth slowed down
under trump
that's factually true is it fair to say
he blew it when
in fact it was right you know when there
was record on low unemployment yeah
before covet
yeah but because what he did even before
covent manufacturing went in the hole
manufacturing went nut whole excuse me
number two number three they said they
would take no you were number two no
chris chris what they said it would take
a miracle
to bring back manufacturing i brought
back seven hundred thousand jobs
they brought back nothing they gave up
on manufacturing we needed my standard
fare
i'm the guy he totally gave him one
manufacturer
we brought back i was asked to bring
back chrysler and general motors who
brought him back right here in the state
of ohio in michigan
he blew it they're gone he blew it and
in fact
they're gone ohio had the best year it's
ever had last year
michigan had the best year they've ever
had it's not any car companies came in
from germany from japan
went to
and so you take a look at what he's
actually done he's done
very little his trade deals are the same
way he talks about these great trade
deals
you know he talks about the art of the
deal china has made perfected the art of
the steel
we have a higher deficit with china now
than we did before
we have the highest deficit trade
deficit china with mexico
china ate your lunch joe and no wonder
your son goes in and he
takes out oh he takes out billions of
dollars
takes out billions of dollars to manage
he makes millions of dollars
and also while we're at it why is it
just out of curiosity
the mayor of moscow's wife gave your son
three and a half million dollars
what did he do to deserve it what did he
do with baristas
not none of that is true mr president
is totally president please totally
discredited
totally discredited and by the way well
wait he didn't get three and a half
million dollars joe
mr vice president he got through the
presidential dollars that is not true
really mr president it's an open
discussion
please it's a fact well there's no who
have raised an issue let the special
president answer discredited 183
000 a month with no experience and
energy
my son did nothing wrong at first i
think he did mr president
he doesn't want to let me answer because
he knows i have the truth they have to
take time you have to have some
mechanism to deal with that
by everybody well by the media by our
allies
by the world bank
by everyone as discredited matter of
fact
matter of fact who testified under oath
so let me ask you this
he testified under oath in his
administration said i did my job and i
did it very well
i did it i'd like to know who they are
every well i'll give you the list
of the people who tested sure they've
you've already fired most of them
because they did a good job
some people don't know but here's it
with you
wait a minute you get the final word
well it's hard to get any word in with
this clown excuse me this
hey let me just say dude no no mr
look here's the deal we want to talk
about
families and ethics i don't want to do
that
i mean his family we could talk about
all night his family's alright my family
my family you're coming down and helping
us with government
and that's such a direction mr president
such a single one of them
this is not about my family or his
family it's about your family doesn't
that's not true it doesn't want to talk
about
what you need you the american people
it's about you that's what we're talking
about all right
that's the end of the segment we're
moving on it didn't take them vice
president
can i be honest it's a very important
try to be honest
no the answer to the question is no
ukraine no i
sir with a billion dollars you know what
you're waiting not
true you're not doing it you're going to
have that okay true this is the downfall
of american democracy guys
why shouldn't i be different than the
two of you i should say here's the good
point
we have six segments we have ended that
segment
we're going to go to the next segment in
that segment you each are going to have
two uninterrupted moments
in those two interrupted minutes mr
president you can say anything you want
i'm going to ask a question about race
but if you want to answer about
something else go ahead
but we i think that the country would be
better served
if we allowed both people to speak with
fewer interruptions
i'm appealing to you sir to do that well
and him too well he's never
been doing more interruptions that's all
right but he does plenty well less than
sir
do people want to get banned for like
mercy bans just so you don't have to
watch this just let the moderators know
to say that president trump's response
to the violence in charlottesville three
years ago
when he talked about very fine people on
both sides
was what directly led you
to launch this run for president oh yeah
sure president
trump you have often said that you
believe you have done
more for black americans than any
president with the possible
exception of abraham lincoln my question
for the two of you
is why should voters trust you rather
than your opponent
to deal with the race issues facing this
country over the next four years
vice president biden you go first it's
about
equity and equality it's about decency
it's about the constitution and we have
never walked away from
trying to quite require equity for
everyone equality for the whole
of america but we've never accomplished
it but we've never
walked away from it like he has done it
is true the reason i got in the race is
with those people
close your eyes remember what those
people look like coming out of the
fields carrying torches
their veins bulging speeding just
spewing
anti-semitic bile and accompanied by the
ku klux klan a young woman got killed
and they asked the president what he
thought he said they were very fine
people on both sides no president has
ever said
anything like that it is no second sir
second point i'd make to you is that
when
floyd was killed when mr floyd was
killed there was a peaceful protest
in front of the white house what did he
do he came out of his bunker
had the military to use tear gas on him
so he could walk across
to a church and hold up a bible and then
what happened
after that the bishop of that very
church said that it was the disgrace
the general who was with him said he
only all he ever wants to do is divide
people
not unite people at all this is a
president who has used everything as a
dog whistle
to try to generate racist hatred racist
division
this is a man who in fact you talk about
helping african americans
one in 1 000 african americans has been
killed because of the conan the
coronavirus and if he doesn't do
something quickly by the end of the year
one in 500 will have been killed one in
500 african-americans
this man this man is the as a savior of
african-americans
this man cares at all this man's done
virtually nothing look the fact is that
you have to look at what he talks about
you have to look at what he did and what
he did has been disastrous
for the african-american community so
president trump you have two minutes
why should americans trust you over
your opponent to deal with racism get a
crime bill 1994.
oh god where you call them super
predators
super predators and they've never
forgotten it they've never forgotten it
jefferson
no sir it's his two minutes so you did
that and they called you a super
predator
i don't think joe said that actually
well now that you have treated the
african-american population community
you have treated the black community
about as bad as anybody in this country
you did the 199 and that's why
if you look at the polls i'm doing
better than any republican has done in a
long time
because they saw what you did you call
them super predators
and you've called them worse than that
because you look back at your testimony
over the years you've called them a lot
worse than that as far as the church is
concerned
and as far as the generals are concerned
we just got the support of 200
mil 250 military leaders and generals
total support law enforcement almost
every law enforcement
group in the united states i have
florida i have texas
i have ohio i have every
excuse me portland the sheriff just came
out today and he said i support
president trump i don't think you have
any law enforcement you can't even say
the word law enforcement because if you
say those words
you're going to lose all of your radical
left supporters and why aren't you
saying those words
why don't you say the words law
enforcement because you know what if
they called us
in portland we would put out that fire
in a half an hour but they won't do it
because they're run by radical left
democrats
if you look at chicago if you look at
any place you want to look seattle
they heard we were coming in the
following day and they put up their
hands and we got back seattle
minneapolis we got it back joe because
we believe in law and order but you
don't
the top 10 cities in just about the top
40 cities
are run by democrats cities are run by
democrats because democrats live in
cities
finger joe to a point where you don't
want to say anything about law and order
and i'll tell you what the people of
this country want and demand
law and order and you're afraid to even
say it all right
to i want to return to the question of
race vice president biden
after the grand jury in the brianna
taylor case
decided not to charge any of the police
with homicide you said it raises the
question quote
whether justice could be equally applied
in america do you believe
that there is a separate but unequal
system of justice for
blacks in this country yes there is a
systemic injustice in this country in
education and work and in
in law enforcement and the way in which
it's enforced
but look the vast majority of police
officers are good decent honorable men
and women
they risk their lives every day to take
care of us but there are some bad apples
and when they occur when they find them
they have to be
sorted out they have to be held
accountable they have to be held
accountable
and what i'm going to do as president
united states is called a
together an entire group of people at
the white house
blow everything from the civil rights
groups to the police officers the police
chiefs
and we're going to work this out we're
going to work this out so we change the
way in which we have more transparency
in when these things happen these cops
aren't happy to see what happened to
to george floyd these cops aren't happy
to see what happened to
brianna taylor most don't like it but we
have to have a system
where people are held accountable when
and by the way violence and response is
never appropriate
never appropriate peaceful protest is
violence is never appropriate right
what is peaceful protest when they run
through the
town and burn down your stores and kill
people
i'd like to continue with the issue of
race i promise we're going to get to the
issue of law and order
in a moment this month your
administration
uh directed federal agencies to end
racial
sensitivity training that addresses
white privilege or critical race theory
why did you decide to do that to end
racial sensitivity training
and do you believe that there is
systemic racism in this country sir
i ended it because it's racist i ended
it because a lot of people were
complaining that they were
asked to do things that were absolutely
insane
that it was a radical revolution that
was taking place
in our military in our schools
all over the place and you know it and
so does everybody else
totally racial sensitivity training if
you were a certain person
you had no status in life it was sort of
a reversal
and if you look at the people we were
paying people hundreds of thousands of
dollars
to teach very bad ideas and frankly very
sick ideas
and and really they were teaching people
to hate our country
and i'm not going to do that i'm not
going gonna allow that to happen what
we have to go back to the core values of
this country
uh-oh they were teaching people that our
country is a horrible place it's a
racist place
and they were teaching people to hate
our country and this is
how authoritarians talk but he's doing
that he's just
he's racist you just don't here's the
deal i know a lot more about it
the fact is that there is racial
insensitivity people have to be made
aware
of what other people feel like what
what insults them what is demeaning to
them it's important that people know
they don't want to many people don't
want to hurt other people's feelings
but it's amazing it makes a big
difference it makes a gigantic
difference in the way a child
is able to grow up and have a self a
sense of self-esteem
it's a little bit like how this guy and
his friends look down on so many people
they look down their nose on people like
it'd be great to force trump to answer
is there systemic racism
people who don't have money they look
down on people who are
of a different faith they look down on
people who are a different color
in fact we're all americans the only way
we're going to bring this country
together
is bring everybody together there's
nothing we cannot do
if we do it together we can take this on
and we can defeat
racism president i mean president trump
sir during the obama
biden administration there was
tremendous division
there was hatred you look at uh ferguson
you look at
you go to very many places look at
oakland look what happened in oakland
look what happened in baltimore look
what happened
frankly it was more violent than what
i'm even seeing now but the reason
this is that the democrats that run
these cities
don't want to talk like you about law
and order violence you still haven't
mentioned island
are you in favor of law and order i'm in
favor of law you follow are you in favor
justice where people get treated fairly
and the fact of the matter is violent
crime went down
17 15 in our administration
all right it's gone up on his watch went
down he's much more he has
all right mr president so is trump
arguing crime is up her crime is down mr
president you're going to be very happy
because we're not going to talk about
law in order
because we had trouble with
democratic-run cities that's exactly my
question
there has been a dramatic increase in
homicides in america
this summer particularly and you often
blame that on democratic
mayors and democratic governors but in
fact there have been equivalent
spikes in republican-led cities like
tulsa and fort worth
so the question is is this really a
party issue
i think it's a party issue you can bring
in a couple of examples but if you look
at chicago what's going on in chicago
where
53 people were shot and eight died shot
if you look at new york where it's going
up like nobody's ever seen anything the
numbers are going up a hundred hundred
and fifty two hundred percent
uh crime it is crazy what's going on
and he doesn't want to say law and order
because he can't because he'll lose his
radical left supporters
and once he does that it's over with but
if he ever got to run this country
and they ran it the way he would want to
run it we would have
our suburbs would be gone by the way our
suburbs would be gone
that's right and you would see problems
like he wouldn't know a suburb unless
you took a wrong turn oh i know subbers
wait a minute i was raised in the
suburbs this is not 1950.
all these dog whistles and racism don't
work anymore suburbs are by and large
integrated
there's many people today driving their
kids to soccer practice and or to
black and white and hispanic in the same
car as there have been any time in the
past
what's what really is a threat to the
suburbs and their safety
is his failure to deal with covet
they're dying in the suburbs right
his failure to deal with the environment
they're being flooded
yeah they're being burned out because
his refusal to do anything
that's why the suburbs are interesting i
do want to talk about this issue of law
and order though and in the joint
recommendation
that came from the biden bernie sanders
task force
you talked about quote reimagining
policing first of all what does
reimagining
policing mean and do you support it
let me if i might finish the question
what does reimagining policing mean
and do you support the black lives
matter
uh call for uh
for community control of policing why
look
what i support is the police having the
opportunity to deal with the problems
they face
and i'm not totally opposed to defunding
the police officers
as a matter of fact police local police
the only one defunding in his budget
calls for a 400 million dollar cut in
local law enforcement assistance
they need more assistance they need when
they show up for a 9 11 call to have
someone with them as a psychologist or
psychiatrist
correct to keep them from having to use
force and be able to talk people down
we have to have community policing like
we had before where the officers get to
know the people
in the communities that's when crime
went down
it didn't go up it went down and so we
have to be in this game
you're talking about christmas that's
not where that is he's talking about
defunding the police that is not true
he doesn't have any law support he has
no
law enforcement that's not true
name one group that supports you name
one group that came out and supported
you this is idiocy
i think we have time we don't have time
to do it all right
one law enforcement group that came back
gentlemen i think i'm going to i'm going
to take back the moderators
and i want to get to another subject
which is the issue of protests in many
cities
that have turned violent in portland
oregon especially we had a
more than 100 straight days of protests
which i think you would agree you talked
about peaceful protests many of those
turned into riots
mr vice president you say that
people who commit crimes should be held
accountable
the question i have though is as the
democratic nominee and earlier tonight
you said that you
are the democratic party right now have
you ever called the democratic mayor of
portland or the democratic governor of
oregon and said
hey you got to stop this bring in the
national guard
do whatever it takes but you'd stop the
days and months of violence
why is the assumption that you bring in
i don't hold public office now
i am a former vice president i've made
it clear
i've made it clear in my public
statements that the violence should be
prosecuted
it should be prosecuted and anyone who
commits it but you've never called for
the people
the leader excuse me sir you had never
called for the leaders in portland
and in oregon to call us bring in the
national guard and knock off
a hundred days of riots they can in fact
tell them take care of it if you just
stay out of the way
look here oh really here oh really
here's the
killer of the uh man in the middle of
the street they shot him
and for three days president trump
didn't do anything
on the u.s marshal business go ahead sir
and by the way
you know his own former spokesperson
said you know
riots and chaos and violence helpless
cause
that's what this is all about i don't
know who said that i do
who i think kellyanne conway i don't
think she said she said that
and so here's all right but here's the
point the point is that
that's what he is keeps trying to rile
everything up
he doesn't want to calm things down
instead of going in
and talking to people and saying let's
get everybody together figure out how to
deal with this
what's he do he just pours gasoline in
the fire
constantly and every single solitary
okay and and to
end this button up this segment i'm
going to give you a minute to answer sir
you have repeatedly criticized i have to
answer his stuff you have mistakes
no you've been talking you made a
statement i'm asking you i would love to
know
sir i would love to you know if you want
to switch seats
you got to cut it right quickly we could
do that but i'm saying the national
guard it would be over there'd be no
problem okay
but they don't want to accept the
national guard you have repeatedly
criticized
the the vice president for not
specifically calling out
antifa and other left-wing extremist
groups
but are you willing tonight to condemn
white supremacists
and militia groups and to say that they
need to stand down and not add to the
violence in a number of these cities as
we saw in kenosha
and as we've seen in portland
i would say almost everything i see is
from the left wing
not from the right what are you what are
you doing what are you saying i'm i'm
willing to do anything i want to see
what he didn't do it sir
say it do it say it do you want to call
him
what do you want to call him give me a
name give me a white surprise
stand back and stand by but i'll tell
you what
i'll tell you what somebody's got to do
something about antifa and the left
because this is not a right-wing problem
director this is a left-wing white
supremacist
antifa is an idea not an organization
you've got it not malicious
that's what is tonight his fbi director
says no no no we're done sir we're
moving on to
your administration tells you the truth
is it has a bad idea can i tell you what
you have no idea
antifa is a dangerous gentleman we're
now moving on to the trump enlightened
records
he'll overthrow you when a president can
ask a question
when the president seeks a second term
it is generally a referendum on his
record
but vice president biden you like to
quote one of your dad's
sayings which is don't compare me to the
almighty
compare me to the alternative in this
case sir
you are the alternative looking
at both of your records i'm going to ask
each of you
why should voters elect you president
over your opponent
in this segment president trump you go
first two minutes
because there has never been an
administration or president
who has done more than i've done in a
period of three and a half years and
that's despite
the impeachment hoax and you saw what
happened today with hillary clinton
where it was a whole big con job
but despite going through all of these
things where i had to fight
both flanks and behind me and above
there has never been an
administration that's done what i've
done the greatest before covet came in
the greatest economy in history lowest
employ
unemployment numbers everything was good
everything was going and by the way
there was unity going to happen people
were calling me for the first time in
years they were calling
and they were saying it's time maybe and
then what happened we got hit but now
we're building it back up again
a rebuilding of the military including
space force and all of the other things
a fixing of the the va which was a mess
under him 308 000 people died because
they didn't have proper health care he
was a mess and we now got a 91 approval
rating
at the va our vets we take care of our
vets but we've rebuilt our military
the job that we've done and i'll tell
you something some people say maybe the
most important
by the end of the first term i'll have
approximately
300 federal judges and court of appeals
judges 300 dystopian
hopefully three great supreme court
judges
justices that is a record
the likes of which very few people and
you know one of the reasons i'll have so
many judges
because president obama and him left me
128
judges to phil when you leave office you
don't leave any judges that's like you
just don't do that
they left 128 openings and if i were a
member of his party
because they have a little different
philosophy i'd say if you left
us 128 openings you can't be a good
president
you can't be a good vice president but i
want to thank you because it gives us
almost
it'll probably be above that number by
the end of this term
300 judges it's a record what looking at
both your records
why should voters elect you president as
opposed to president trump you have two
minutes uninterrupted
under this president we become weaker
sicker
poor more divided and more violent
when i was vice president we inherited a
recession
i was asked to fix it i did we left him
a booming economy
and he caused a recession with regard to
being weaker
the fact is that i've gone head-to-head
with putin
and made it clear to him we're not going
to take any of his stuff he's putin's
puppy he still refuses to even say
anything to putin about
the bounty on the heads of american
soldiers
million dollars and by the way mr price
wait a minute mr president your campaign
agreed
to both sides would get two minute
answers uninterrupted well
your side agreed to it and why don't you
observe what your campaign agreed to as
a ground rule okay sir
he never keeps his word no no no i'm not
absolutely
that was a rhetorical question can you
go ahead back 30 seconds
yeah trump take it literally go ahead so
thirdly we're poor the billionaires have
gotten much
started to explain why you won't shut up
by a tune of over four three to four
hundred billion dollars more
just since covent you in the home you
got
less you're in more trouble than you
were before
in terms of being more violent when we
were in office there were 15 percent
less violence in america than there is
today he's president united states
it's on his watch and with regard to
more divided
the nation can't stay divided we can't
be this way and speaking of my son the
way you talk about the military
the way you talk about them being losers
and being
and and just being suckers yes my son
was in iraq he spent a year there
he got he got the bronze star he got the
conspicuous service medal
he was not a loser he was a patriot
and the people left behind there were
heroes
and i resent you talking about are you
talking about i'm talking about my son
beau biden you're talking i don't know
i don't know beau i know hunter hunter
got thrown hunter got thrown out of the
military
he was thrown out dishonorably
discharged that's not true cocaine news
and he didn't have a job until you
became vice president what do you mean
he made a fortune in ukraine in china in
moscow that is simply various
other places son and he didn't have a
joke my son
like a lot of people like a lot of
people we know at home had a
drug problem he's overtaken it he's he's
he's fixed it he's worked on it and i'm
proud of him but why was he out of my
head
we've already been through this i think
the american people would rather hear
about more substantial well you know
as the moderator sir i'm going to make a
judgement call here three and a half
million
dollars from the mayor of moscow i think
that report is totally i was credited
mitt romney on that committee said it
wasn't worth taxpayers money that
reporter is written for political
reasons you know
i'd like to talk about climate change so
and i okay
the forest fires in the west are raging
now they have burned
millions of acres they have displaced
hundreds of thousands of people when
state officials there blame the fires on
climate change mr president you said
i don't think the science knows over
your four years
you have pulled the us out of the paris
climate accord
you have rolled back a number of obama
environmental
records what do you believe about the
science of climate change
and what will you do in the next four
years to confront it
i want crystal clean water and air i
want beautiful clean air we have now the
lowest carbon
if you look at our numbers right now we
are
doing phenomenally but i haven't
destroyed our businesses
our businesses aren't put out of
commission if you look at
the paris accord it was a disaster from
our standpoint
and people are actually very happy about
what's going on
because our businesses are doing well as
far as the fires are concerned
you need forest management in addition
to everything else untrue
the forest floors are loaded up with
trees dead trees that are years old and
i like
tinder and leaves and everything else
you drop a cigarette in there the whole
forest burns down
you've got to have forest management
what do you believe what do you believe
about the science of climate change sir
uh i believe that we have to do
everything we can to have
immaculate air immaculate water and do
whatever else we can that's good you
know we're planting a billion trees the
billion tree project
and it's very exciting that human
pollution gas greenhouse gas emissions
contributes to the global warming
i think a lot of things do but i think
to an extent yes i think to an extent
yes but i also think
we have to do better management of our
foreign
i get the call california's burning
california is burning
if that was cleaned if that were if you
had forest management good
forest management you wouldn't be
getting those calls you know in europe
they live their forest cities they call
forest cities they maintain their forest
they manage their forests
i was with the head of a major country
major it's a forest city not a minority
i said sir
we have trees that are far more they
they ignite
much easier in california there
shouldn't be that problem i spoke with
the governor about it i'm getting along
very well with the governor
but i said you know at some point you
can't every year have
hundreds of thousands of acres of land
just burned to the ground that's burning
down because of a lack of
sir if you believe in the science of
climate change
why have you rolled back the obama clean
power plan which
limited carbon emissions in power plants
why would you relax because it was
driving
energy prices through the sky why have
you relaxed fuel economy
standards that are going to create more
pollution from cars well not really
because what's happening is the car
is much less expensive and it's a much
safer car
and you're talking about a tiny
difference and then what would happen
because of the cost of the car you would
have at least
double and triple the number of cars
purchased we have the old slugs out
there
two or three more cars purchased that's
a lot of cars driving around
it would be much cheaper but yeah
they've simply
take a lot of cars off the market
because people would be able to afford a
car
now so and by the way we're going to see
how that turns out but a lot of people
agree with me many people
the car has gotten so expensive because
they have computers all over the place
for an extra little bit of gasoline and
and i'm okay with electric cars too i
think i'm all for electric cars i've
given big incentives for electric cars
but what they've done in california is
just crazy
vice president biden i'd like you to
respond to the president's climate
change record but i also want to ask you
about a concern you proposed two
trillion dollars in green
jobs you talk about new limits not
abolishing but new limits on fracking
ending the use of fossil fuels to
generate electricity by 2035
and zero net emission of greenhouse
gases by 2050.
the president says a lot of these things
would
tank the economy and cost millions of
jobs he's absolutely wrong
number one number two if in fact when
our during our administration the
recovery act i was able to i was in
charge able to bring down the cost
of renewable energy to cheaper than or
as cheap as
coal and gas and oil nobody's going to
build another
uh coal-fired plant in america no one's
going to build another oil-fired plant
in america
they're going to move to renewable
energy number one number two
we're going to make sure that we are
able to take the federal fleet and turn
it into a fleet that's
run on their electric vehicles making
sure that we can do that we're going to
put 500
000 charging stations and all of the
highways that we're going to be building
in the future
we're going to build a economy that in
fact is going to provide for
the ability us to take four million
buildings and make sure that they in
fact are
weatherized in a way that in fact
they'll emit significantly less gas and
oil because the heat will not be going
out
there's so many things that we can do
now to create
thousands and thousands of jobs we can
get to net
zero in terms of energy production
by 2035 not only not costing people jobs
creating jobs
creating millions of good paying jobs
not 15 bucks an hour
but prevailing wage by having a new
infrastructure that in fact is green
and the first thing i will do i will
rejoin the paris accord
i will join the paris accord because
with us out of it look what's happening
it's all falling apart and talk about
someone who has
no no relationship to with foreign
policy
brazil the rainforest of brazil are
being torn down are being ripped down
more more carbon is absorbed in that
rainforest than every bit of carbon
that's admitted in the united states
instead of doing something about that i
would be gathering up and making sure we
had to come
the countries of the world coming up
with 20 billion dollars say here's 20
billion dollars
stop stop tearing down
the forest and if you don't then you're
going to have significant
economic consequences what about the
argument that president trump basically
says that you have to balance
environmental interests and economic
interests and he's drawn his line
well he hadn't drawn a line he still for
example make sure that we he wants to
make sure that
methane is not a problem we can you you
can now emit more methane
that's not a problem methane this is a
guy who says that
you don't have to have mileage standards
for automobiles that exist now
this is the guy who says that well the
fact that
it's all true and here's what's talking
about the green new deal and it's not 2
billion
or 20 billion as you said it's 100
trillion dollars i'm talking about where
they want to rip down
buildings and rebuild the building it's
the
most redundant where airplanes are out
of business
where two car systems are out where they
want to take out the cows too
you know that's not true either right
and count this is a this is a 100
trillion
that's more money than our country could
make in 100 years if we're not
the case all right let me let me let me
just because i actually wait a minute
sir i actually have studied your plan
and it includes upgrading four million
buildings weatherizing two million homes
over four years
building one and a half million energy
efficient
homes so the question becomes some the
president is saying i
think some people who support the
president would say that sounds
like it's going to cost a lot of money
and hurt the economy what it's going to
do it's going to create
thousands and millions of jobs good
paying jobs let him finish sir
he doesn't know how to do that billion
dollars the fact is it's going to create
millions of good paying jobs and these
tax incentives to people for people to
weatherize which he wants to get
get rid of it's going to make the
economy much safer look how much we're
paying now
to deal with the hurricanes with the
deal with by the way he has an answer
for hurricanes he said
maybe we should drop a nuclear weapon on
them they may i never said that
actually he did made it up uh and here's
the deal you make up
we we're going to be in a position where
we can create
hard hard good jobs by making sure the
environment
is clean and we all are in better shape
we spend
billions of years billions of dollars
on floods hurricanes rising seas
we're in real trouble look what's
happening just in the midwest with these
storms that come through and wipe out
entire sections and counties
in iowa that didn't happen before
they're because of global
warming we make up 15 of the world's
problem we in fact but the rest of the
world we've got to get them to come
along that's what we have to get back
into back into the paris accord all
right gentlemen wait a minute chris so
why didn't he do it for 47 years you
were vice president why didn't you get
the world
china sends up real dirt into the air
russia does
india does they all do we're supposed to
be good and by the way
he made a couple of statements the green
new deal is a hundred trillion dollars
that is not
my plan that's great well we want to
rebuild everything
my plan i want to rebuild everyone knew
anything about it
he made a statement about the military
he said i said something about the
military
he and his friends made it up and then
they went with it i never said it okay
that is the vice president
he said stupid best totally out of
confidence
his final question the final question is
i can't remember which of all is ranties
i'm having a little trouble myself but
and about the economy and about this
question
of what it's going to cost i mean the
green new deal and the idea of what what
your environmental changes will do the
green new deal
will pay for itself as we move forward
we're not going to build
plants that in fact are great polluting
plants are you going to build a brand
new deal
pardon me do you support no i don't
support the greens don't oh well that's
a big statement
i support you just the radical left i
suppose
i support the radical left will go vote
for trump now that i put forward
okay the biden plan which is different
than what he
calls the radical green new deal all
right gentlemen final segment
election integrity as we meet tonight
millions of americans
are receiving mail-in ballots or going
to vote early
how confident should we be that this
will be a fair election and what are you
prepared to do
over the next five plus weeks because it
will not only be to election day
but also counting some ballots mail-in
ballots after election
trump can help what are you prepared to
do to reassure the american people that
the next president
will be the legitimate winner of this
election
in this final segment mr vice president
you go first prepared to let people vote
they should go to iwillvote.com
decide how they're going to vote when
they're going to vote and what means by
which they're going to vote
his own homeland security director as
well as the fbi director says there is
no evidence at all that mail and ballots
are a source of of being manipulated and
cheating
they said that the fact is that there
are going to be millions of people
because of covet
that are going to be voting by mail and
ballots like he does by the way he sits
behind the resolute desk and sends his
ballot to florida
number one number two we're going to
make sure that those people who
want to vote in person are able to vote
because enough poll watchers are there
to
make sure they can socially distance the
polls are open on time
and their polls stay open until the
votes are counted and this is all about
trying to dissuade
people from voting because he's trying
to con
to scare people into thinking that it's
not going to be legitimate
show up and vote you will determine the
outcome of this election
vote vote vote if you're able to vote
early in your state
vote early if you're able to vote in
person
vote whatever way is the best way for
you because you
will he cannot stop you from being able
to determine the outcome of this
election
and in terms of whether or not when the
votes are counted and they're all
counted
that will be accepted if i win that will
be accepted if i lose that'll be
accepted but by the way
if in fact he says he's not sure what
he's going to accept
well let me tell you something it
doesn't matter because if we get the
votes
it's going to be all over he's going to
go yeah he can't stay in power yes it
won't happen
yes it won't happen so vote just make
sure you understand
you have it in your control to determine
what this country's going to look like
the next four years
please is it going to change you get
four more years of these lies
mr president two minutes so when i
listened to joe talking about a
transition
uh there's been no transition from when
i won i won that election
and if you look at crooked hillary
clinton if you look at all of the
different people
why there was no transition because they
came after me trying to do a coup
she came after me spying on my campaign
they started from the day i won and even
before i won from the day i came down
the escalator with our first lady
they were a disaster they were disgraced
to our country
and we've caught them we've caught them
all we've got it all on tape we've
caught them all and by the way you gave
the idea for the logan act against
general flynn
you better take a look at that because
we caught you in a sense and
president obama was sitting in the
office he knew about it too so don't
tell me about a free transition
as far as the balance reconciliation
it's a disaster
a solicited ballot okay
solicited is okay you're so listening
you're asking they send it back you send
it back
i did that if you have an unsolicited
they're sending millions of ballots all
over the country
there's fraud they found him in creeks
they found some with the name trump just
happened to have the name trump
just the other day in a waste paper
basket they're being sent all over the
place
they sent two in a democrat area they
sent out a thousand ballots everybody
got two ballots
this is going to be a fraud like you've
never seen the other thing
it's nice on november 3rd you're
watching and you see who won the
election
and i think we're going to do well
because people are really happy with the
job we've done
but you know what we won't know we might
not know for months
years because these ballots are going to
be all over take a look at what happened
in manhattan take a look at what
happened in
new jersey take a look at what happened
in virginia and other places
they're not losing two percent one
percent which by the way is that much an
election could be won or lost with that
they'll listen 30 and 40 it's a fraud
and it's a shame and can you imagine
where they say
uh you have to have your ballot in by
november 10th
november 10th that means that's seven
days
after the election in theory should have
been announced okay we have major states
with
you have been charging for months and
mail-in balloting is going to be a
disaster
you say it's rigged that it's going to
lead to fraud
but in 2018 in the last midterm election
31 million
people voted mail-in voting that was
a quarter more than a quarter of all the
voters that year cast their ballots by
mail
now that millions of mail-in ballots
have gone out
what are you going to do about it and
are you counting on the supreme court
including a justice barrett to settle
any dispute
i'm getting them to look at the ballots
definitely i don't think well i hope we
don't need them
in terms of the election itself but for
the ballots i think so
because what's happening is incredible i
just heard i read today where at least
one percent of the ballots for 2016
were invalidated they they take them we
don't like them we don't like them they
throw them out
there are millions of ballots going on
what you do is you go and vote you do a
solicited ballot no no that's okay i
know where you going
i'm asking you about the fact that
millions of people you go and vote
you go and vote but like they used to
millions of people you either do chris a
solicited ballot where you're sending it
in they're sending it back and you're
sending
they have mailman with lots of it did
you see what's going on take a look at
west virginia mailman selling the
ballots
they're being sold they're being dumped
in rivers this is a horrible thing for
our country
this is not there is no this is not
going to end
well
for the last decade or more five
including two republican states
and you don't have to solicit the ballot
it's sent to you it's
sent to your home what we're saying is
they're saying is that has to be a
postmark
by the time by election day if it
doesn't get in until the
seventh eighth ninth it still should be
counted
he's just afraid of counting the votes
because you're wrong
vice president biden the biggest problem
in fact over the years with mail-in
voting
has not been fraud historically it has
been that
sizable numbers sometimes hundreds of
thousands of ballots are thrown out
because they have not been properly
filled out or there is some other
irregularity or they must be through the
deadline so the question i have is
are you concerned that the supreme court
with a justice barrett
will settle any dispute i'm concerned
that any court would settle this because
here's the deal
when you when you file when you get a
ballot
and you fill it out you're supposed to
have an affidavit if you didn't know you
have
someone say that this is me you should
be able to
if in fact you can verify that you when
the before the ballot is thrown out
that's sufficient to be able to count
the ballot because someone made a
mistake
and not dotting the correct die who they
voted for
testify say who they voted for
say it's you that is totally legitimate
all right excited
million dollars
election workers are prohibited
currently by law eight states
from even beginning to process ballots
even take them out of the envelopes and
flatten them until election day that
means that it's likely because there's
going to be a huge increase
in male invaliding that we are not going
to know
on election night who the winner is that
it could be days
it could be weeks until we find out who
the
the new president is so five days first
for you sir
finally for the for the vice president i
hope neither of you will interrupt the
other
will you urge your supporters to stay
calm
during this extended period not to
engage in any
civil unrest and will you pledge tonight
that you will not declare
victory until the election has been
independently certified
president trump thank you for joining my
supporters to go into the polls
and watch very carefully because that's
what has to happen i am
urging them to do it as you know today
there was a big problem
in philadelphia they went in to watch
they were called poll watchers a very
safe very nice thing
they were thrown out they weren't
allowed to watch you know why
because bad things happen in
philadelphia bad things well you have to
sign i am emerging
i am urging my people i hope it's going
to be a fair election if it's a fair
election
i am 100 on board but if i see
tens of thousands of ballots being
manipulated i can't go along with that
and i'll tell you what is that from a
common sense does that mean you're
telling other people
it means you have a fraudulent election
you're sending out 80 million
they're not equipped these people aren't
equipped to handle it
number one number two they cheat
they found ballots in a waste paper
basket
three days ago and they all had the name
military ballots they were military
they all had the name trump on them vice
versa i think that's good
vice president biden final question for
you will you urge your supporters to
stay calm
of course while the vote is counted and
will you pledge
not to declare victory until the
election is independently certified
yes and here's the deal simple you count
the balance as you pointed out
some of these ballots in some states
can't even be opened until
election day and if there's thousands of
ballots going to take time to do it and
by the way
our military they've been voting by
ballots
first since at the end of the civil war
in effect and that's
and that's what's happened going to
happen why was it not why is it for them
somehow not fraudulent it's the same
process
it's honest no one has established at
all
that there is fraud related to male
imbalance that this somehow it's a
fraudulent process it's already been
established
caroline maloney's racism you had an
opportunity
no one's even alleged fraud in that race
no idea what he's talking about here's
the deal
the fact is i will accept it and he will
too you know why
because once the winner is declared
after all the
all the ballots are counted it's all the
votes are counted it's over that'll be
the end of it
that'll be the end of it and if it's me
in fact fine if
if it's not me i'll support the outcome
and i'll be a president not just for the
democrats i'll be a president for
democrats and republicans
and this guy i want to say honestly
gentlemen
as we go on uh president trump
vice president biden has been an
interesting hour and a half i want to
thank you both
for participating in the first of three
debates that you have agreed to engage
in we want to thank case western reserve
university
and the cleveland clinic for hosting
this event the next debate sponsored by
the commission on presidential debates
will be one week from tomorrow october
7th at the university of utah
vp in salt lake city the two vice
presidential nominees vice president
mike pence and senator kamala harris
will debate at 9 pm eastern that night
we hope you watch
until then thank you and good night
so listen guys i'm going to give you my
assessment is trump saying anything to
joe there it's hard to tell
what's going on let's keep an eye out
here trump is pointing
at the 2020 election cycle uh let's take
a look at what happens don't leave
because i have i i have an
offer for you and a request so
there's melania uh oh my god this is
pathetic
okay so listen guys here's my request
and here's my offer
my request is um if you want to be
notified of future
uh debate streams then just subscribe if
you're watching on youtube or follow if
you're watching on twitch it's free it's
quick it's easy okay we've got 1.02
million subscribers on youtube
help us make it 1.03 if you're watching
on twitch we've got 51 000 followers
let's make it 52 000.
it's free that's my ask of you now i
have an offer for you
if you want a mercy ban if you were
as distraught by this as i was quite
frankly
and you want a mercy ban from the
moderators so that you can't watch the
future debates i would understand it
i would understand it and you can ask
for a mercy ban
in the chat and you know moderators will
evaluate it and then they will decide if
you know
you you have uh achieved a worthy status
for a mercy ban so
if you want to watch the next ones i
really would appreciate if you subscribe
or follow it's free
and if you need my help not to watch the
next one just
ask for the mercy ban and then we will
put you out of your misery
from the standpoint of my channels
uh okay i think i probably will take a
few voice calls on our discord as i pr
i promised you guys know i stick to my
promises here
all right davidpakman.com discord
you can get in the how do you do i don't
even know how to you do it
you get in the waiting lobby the audio
waiting lobby
okay and then i'll take i'll hear from a
few people we have had 286 people
sign up on our website joinpakman.com
today
help me get to 300 okay that's our
primary funding source
and just 14 more and we will knock out a
record
that we have never seen before 300 new
website members
during one uh during during one stream
thank you to people who have gifted and
subscribed over on twitch
thank you to people who have sent super
chats people
in via super chat saying open the phone
lines
we did i did say if we got 50 000 live
viewers i would open the phone lines
we had 64 000 live concurrent 64 000
live concurrent across various
platforms it is a record for us and i
will indeed open up the phone lines we
are going to do it via discord
so please go to davidpakman.com
discord and you can get in the waiting
lobby okay i'm gonna just talk to a few
people
it is a school night very very powerful
evening
um but there is there's really something
for everybody now here's my assessment
of the debate okay
that was not a good performance by joe
biden it it just wasn't
he he seemed unsure and unstable
he had three maybe four strong answers
but donald trump is completely out of
his mind
he's talking like a dictator he's
talking like an authoritarian he's
dancing around
will he actually denounce white
supremacists and same
he said militias should stand by when he
asked them to stand
down i mean he had no substantive
answers so
you know i'm not the target here you're
probably not the target the question is
the the sort of uh
you know average undecided or or person
who's unsure
if they're going to vote or not going to
vote i don't know how this impacted them
i'm going to take the night to think
about it you know it's like
biden was slow trump was nuclear out of
his mind it's just not even a comparison
and uh but listen i see people saying
biden did well he called
wrecked tprg says biden did well and
called trump out to his face yes
biden had four or so good answers
he had three or so call outs that i
think were good
i i don't i'd be i'm not gonna lie to
you and tell you it was great i think it
was
probably good enough given how much of a
disaster donald trump was you know
um all right let's hear from a few
people
davidpakman.com discord please be ready
i don't even know how this works
i'm gonna try now let me just see
uh okay how do i do this i do i just
press
do i just press someone um
i need to drag them into the live room
how the hell do i do this i don't i
still don't know
voice chat waiting lobby
can someone tell me how to do this i see
a bunch of people
in waiting lobby what do i do in order
to bring them on does anybody know
holy [ __ ] what a system i guess do i
drag them
into the recording studio and then i
join
okay i think we're on with someone let
me see who's on here
uh hold on a second who am i on with
wombat
master can you hear me wombat master
i can hear you david wow what's on your
mind what did you think
well okay so i live in the iron range of
minnesota manufacturing is a very
important thing
trump has done nothing for anyone up
here it's amazing how angry
and vehemently terrible that guy was
biden looked like your old ass uncle
sorry for swearing
your old uncle who definitely looked
like you know he's not gonna be around
for too much longer
i just hope people see this and really
get out there and get involved in your
local politics getting
care about local elections or we're just
going to let these people
not listen to the people in their 30s
40s and 20s anymore
all right very good so so is your is
yours a message of optimism i have a
hard time telling
um it is it is we'll call it kasha's
optimism okay i think we'll get there
i think maybe once we're all hopped up
on halloween candy
i think i think that'll help all right
very good wombat master
and let's see now uh how we take people
off all right i took someone off
let me now i think i'm getting the hang
of this we are we are hearing from
people
let's go to hold on a second let's go to
uh let's go to jessie b jessie b
are you with me jessie b
bailed okay let's go to um
jethro bodine jethro bodine how are you
jethro bodine you're on live
hey uh david can you hear me i can
hey david um so uh i i definitely agree
with your assessment that
biden wasn't great but trump literally
had a meltdown
in front of our faces on live tv right
probably my biggest concern was when uh
he said he's urging his his supporters
his
people to watch the polls people are
going to interpret that
any number of different ways absolutely
that
that scares the absolute hell out of me
absolutely um
however i did literally stand and
applaud
joe biden telling him to shut up to his
face i've been begging to do that
since 2015. yeah biden had a few good
moments that was good when he mentioned
injecting bleach it was good i thought
the lowest blow was when trump talked
about hunter biden and cocaine i thought
that was just disgusting
that was that was abhorrent for a second
i thought he was even confusing
uh bow and hunter yeah like like for a
second there i thought he was literally
confusing bo biden
with hunter and like that that my jaw
hit the floor i was like but i mean
he didn't necessarily recover either
also by the way when trump said
yeah who do you want me to condemn but
then he didn't actually condemn anybody
he he called out the proud boys he
literally name-dropped the proud boys
without being like
unprompted exactly that was
that was another kind of like holy [ __ ]
moment because you know
that the whole thing with roger stone
being in touch with the proud boys
i don't think you can convince me that
trump isn't still in contact with roger
stone in any way
like kind of i mean tinfoil hat time but
like pulling the strings in a way you
know yeah well you know let's
let's stop listen we have enough actual
conspiracies we don't need to go into
hypothetical ones
jethro listen i appreciate hearing from
you really appreciate you watching with
us today
thanks david appreciate it there's
jethro let's go next
to uh this is actually working okay
let's go next to ethan
ethan you're on live hey david can you
hear me i can what's going on
so i just had uh two quick questions
sure uh
about well first off i want to say that
was a total joke
yeah trump was insane embarrassing
but by the way chris wallace was no not
great either i thought the questions
were mediocre
but if you don't you have to have some
way of controlling it and if you don't
think you can you need a mute button you
need you need to be able to cut people's
mic
yeah so that was one of my uh questions
was do you think that
future um moderators are going to be
able to
deal with trump because it wasn't great
there may be rules about whether the
moderator is even allowed
a mic cut i don't think you'll need it
for kamala with mike pence but they're
gonna need to figure this out for the
next debate because this was just an
embarrassment
yeah and uh another question is
do you think that this will uh do you
think either performance will
uh was a negative or positive for both
of them so do you think
trump had a negative uh performance in
that he'll lose support and do you think
biden had a performance where he would
gain support or lose support um what are
your thoughts on that
i don't think either performance was bad
enough that anybody's base is going to
abandon them and
ultimately that's really what this may
be about if you take a qualitative
analysis like for example alan lichtman
who believes that the keys to who wins
are qualitative not about debates or
whatever
i don't think either did so did so
poorly that their base will abandon them
and in that case i
my guess is the debates will end up
being a non-factor
okay yeah uh
just a closing thing is you know i
i agree with you where you are saying
that um biden didn't have a great
performance because
i thought several times you know i had a
physical reaction to some to some of his
uh
blunders but yeah you know i don't think
that's you can even
bring that up in comparison to to what
trump did tonight because
i mean it was insanity at points it was
just
painful to try to listen to it yeah it's
globally embarrassing hurting my ears
yeah no i agree with you i agree with
you all right ethan thank you very much
great to hear from you we're just seeing
hearing from a few people
oh you know who's holding our our big
time supporter chaka seki we've never
spoken before
chaka seki you're on live
yellow
chakaseki
chakaseki are you muted
oh boy all right i've got to move
chakaseki back to the lobby that's too
bad
uh let's go to um anthony v
anthony v hello you are you are live
uh hey david can you hear me i can i'm
gonna turn you down a little because
you're coming in very hot apologize i'll
put my mic away a little bit
what can i do for are we good are we
good now we are we are
all right um so overall my perspective
um i mean i think both sides got um
out of their uh out of their favorite
guy what they wanted
um biden was very much more substance
while uh trump was more abstract
stuff that he would want that is maybe
the biggest understatement that i've
ever heard
trump's approach was a more abstract
approach i like that
right and one one of my bigger concerns
just for um just for the
the results of this debate um chris
wallace was
it you could kind of see the perspective
of like a trump voter saying oh
chris wallace was siding with biden
because he was going back and forth with
trump
because trump would be interrupting uh
biden which like from our perspective
we're like well of course he would do
that he's the moderator he needs to do
his job
yeah but there the trump voters are just
gonna say oh man
the fake news is siding with the
democrats and um
i hope that that rhetoric doesn't uh
backfire too much
i don't think you know listen the
average american who's trying to figure
out who to vote for
is not going to be influenced by after
the fact
republicans saying that wallace was
tougher on trump than he was on biden i
just think the stakes in this election
are so much bigger than that
right that's my sense but right but uh
but overall
um i think biden did a bit better than
most people would
suspect he would do yeah um i think a
lot of people put him down saying oh he
would just be a
blubbering mess um trump pretty much
exactly what i predicted i feel like you
know any any question he was posed i
could kind of predict
the things he would say and i was mostly
right and it's been the exact same
bullet points trump's been using during
his press briefings and during
everything it was
it was the same the same stuff over and
over again yeah and
and i think what baida needs to do more
in the future
is just bring up some of the stuff trump
has said um he did a few he did that a
few times uh the bleach injections
nuking hurricanes um these insane things
that trump
brings up on a daily basis he just needs
to
bring those up so much more and i tend
to agree with you
i tend to agree with you all right
anthony appreciate hearing from you hope
to hear from you again i really
appreciate that we've had a second
successful level five hype train over on
twitch
we've had 325 people sign up on my
website
we've had super chats exploding they've
been coming in like a faucet
not trump's faucet we know trump seems
to have problems with plumbing but
like normal faucets that i have let's
hear from a couple of other people
why don't we go to vanity vanity what's
going on
vanity are you with us
i hear background noise vanity but you
can speak now
oh sorry i think there's a delay between
your stream and the discord calls
yes you should only be listening on the
discord not the stream okay
yeah okay thank you awesome
yeah um that that was a that was kind of
a surreal experience the debate
yes um what really what really scared me
was um
when trump said uh i think he said i
think america needs to go to court
go back to our core values when talking
about race theory implementation and
things like that
completely authoritarian dog whistle red
meat i agree with you
yeah that that kind of that kind of
scared me and i was like core values
what what core values are you talking
about this is the same thing as trump's
talking point about we're going to bring
back patriotic education it's vague
but but it's a it's a very it's very
clear dog whistle
yeah yeah yeah awesome yeah just wanted
to
say that that was that was really
concerning for me all right vanity thank
you so much great to hear from you
uh guys i i promised i would talk to
people and i am doing it i stick to my
word
let's see who else we've got here
um let me see if there's any sort of
vips so to speak although everybody's
very special but just see if anybody i
recognize the thing is on discord
it's not people's real names it's just
handles
so you know if you're a known caller
if you change your handle to a name i'd
recognize you would probably have a
better shot at getting on
let's go to uh let's go to
big paps big paps
uh can you hear me
hmm hold on a second what's going on all
right big pap
sorry can you hear me now
hmm you seem muted on your end big paps
i can't unmute you can you
unmute
all right big paps one other opportunity
i have not muted you wait
wait wait here can you hear me now there
you are you almost lost it there
i know i i was you know dealing with
stuff
uh i have a couple questions that i just
wanted to ask you uh
first of all i didn't find the debate
memorable at all
it was very uninteresting i thought that
the answers
nothing really hit home uh it was really
hard to understand everything especially
because of
the amount of interruptions that was
ridiculous
give me a migraine i wanted to ask you
what what moment did you find most
memorable in the debate considering i
found
very most of it uninteresting and you
know if you said to me
of the entire 90 minutes what stands out
it was the vile moment where trump
brought up hunter's cocaine like if i
had to drill down one moment it's sort
of that i kind of agree it it was almost
everything just felt wrong yeah
everything just felt
why would you bring sons into it i mean
biden answered that very well saying
that you could
talk all night about the you know the
trump family and he's so right about
that
i i have a couple other questions you
know what upset you the most all right
i guess actually you answered that a
little bit what excited you the most
what excited you the most in this debate
what
what got you excited out of your seat a
little bit
honestly biden's closing about voting
i thought was maybe one of his strongest
four moments and people there's
something called
uh a peak end bias it's a behavioral
economics heuristic which daniel
kahneman wrote about and people tend to
remember
uh the the peak and people tend to
remember the
end and if the end was biden talking
about voting followed by
two minutes of literal unhinged insanity
from donald trump
that probably is good for biden i think
yeah i completely agree with you uh that
last closing line that biden did
showed who was the president for all of
america and who was the president
for a much smaller percent of america
i i completely agree with you and if
that's you know for the for the few
undecideds
you know that are out there if that's
what they remember i think it helps
biden and hurts trump
100 well thanks for having me in the
little discord
thanks for calling in i appreciate it
all right big paps is gone
we'll talk to a couple of other people
uh let's go to
jason torn jason torn you can go ahead
and unmute and uh maybe tell me what you
thought about the debate
jason torn you are still muted it is it
is a self mute i have not imposed it on
you
so you need to unmute
you can unmute jason torn if you are
there
all right jason torn is
out did not unmute let's go to
uh let's go to kenny from berkeley kenny
from berkeley you were on
uh i was gonna ask for name in town but
i guess you're kenny from berkeley
yeah what up david how you doing good
how are you
oh well i'm kind of wallowing in the
misery that was
well this whole year yeah and you know
this debate performance
i don't know what the last caller was
saying about it not being memorable i
thought it was particularly
memorably bad in total you mean
oh yeah in total like in grand sum i i
think we're going to look back on this
my friends and i are currently debating
if this will be the only one of the year
but i think we'll remember this as
legendarily awful
it was in total it was awful i think the
previous caller was asking more about
what particular moments were memorable
and pointing out that there weren't that
many
but in total this is the worst
presidential debate
i've ever seen and i've been watching
presidential debates since i guess
1996 really that's why i was born let's
go
this is the worst debate i can ever
remember yeah i
can't say i remember debates to my
infancy but
uh so i've been watching them i guess i
i vaguely remember carrie bush that was
really my first one
right so i guess i was eight for that so
yeah
i remember that crap um but
so i wanted to ask you a question if you
don't mind sure um
so i've been talking with my mother my
mother is she's
basically always voted republican and
she kind of drinks the kool-aid when it
comes to hillary being
evil she's not like a q a non-conspiracy
theorist or anything okay
but she objects to hillary in much the
way that the right wing would before
people like you and me would object to
hillary clinton just
as an example okay um she's
she voted for gary johnson in 2016
because you know she's basically
sticking her tongue out at
both sides which i totally understand
but in talking to her tonight she was
kind of disappointed to see joe biden
she said also stun stoop to trump's
level and
participate in the name calling i didn't
really catch that happening as much
i mean i guess biden referred to trump
as a clown um that's true
but but no i mean listen trump sort of
softly did the biden doesn't remember or
know anything dementia stuff
uh he said biden's stupid he talked
about being at the bottom of his class
and stuff like that i mean yeah you know
biden said just shut up
and he called him a clown but i mean
listen if if that disqualifies biden
then isn't trump also disqualified
uh yes and i think that's her whole
point she'll never vote for trump
um her whole thing was to try to so
she lives in rhode island and her whole
thing was to try to get i guess the
local libertarian party to
a five percent threshold for more
representation which i think is a
somewhat valiant way to vote but
this is kind of a tragedy of the commons
thing right if if none of us
decide to pick one the lesser of two
evils then
in this case that the trump supporters
are just going to win that's right
this is this is not this is not the year
for third party stuff this is a year to
run up the score
listen kenny are you calling me from a
server room or something
um actually no i have a fan on the fan
okay no no problem just wondering
uh all right very good kenny i
appreciate hearing from you
how's that just out of curiosity uh yeah
it's a little better better it's a
little better
okay good to hear well david i
appreciate what you're doing congrats on
the one mill you're awesome i've been
uh watching you um every day in
uh on the members show for about six
months now so i really appreciate what
you're doing
keep up the good work um say hi to pat
and uh
hoping to get back to new england
sometime in the near future all right we
will do it kenny from berkeley very much
appreciate that thanks for being a
member also by the way
thanks to the 330 oh wait it's 336.
we've never seen anything like this you
know when trump bullshits and says
you're gonna see numbers like you've
never seen before and it's obviously a
lie
we have never seen 336 new website
members in a single day we've just never
seen it
we've never seen it so with the stroke
of 11 p.m here on the east
i i never knew what that meant but i
like it the stroke of eleven
um we are going to end our coverage for
today
please before you head out if you are
watching on youtube hit the subscribe
button so you'll be notified of our
vp debate stream next week if you're
watching
on twitch please click the follow button
so that you'll be notified of future
streams
big thank you to levy rosman gotham
chess for the raid
earlier in the evening over on twitch
uh which we i did see but we were in the
middle of a bunch of different things
and uh we are going to have a little a
little bit of the convalescent plasma
song to play us out i'll see everybody
tomorrow on the show vp debate next week
what an evening to
make a truly historic announcement in
our battle against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
convalescent flows from strong
antibodies
from the blood of recovered patients to
help treat patients battling a current
infection
convalescence
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
million lives to fund the mayo clinic
study that tested the
efficacy of convalescence
the virus